donc je suis très heureux que nous
puissions ce matin accueillir jean
pierre farandou qui est le président
directeur général de sncf
monsieur maniche et qui est président
directeur général de sept voyageurs et
monsieur frédéric de langue est présent
directeur général de fret sncf
donc monsieur delorme sera uniquement en
audio puisqu'il a un petit problème de
caméra
j'indique cela pour mes collègues
sénateurs
messieurs les présidents merci d'avoir
c'était de participer à cette audition
nous avons auditionné la semaine
dernière jean baptiste djebbari
secrétaire d'état aux transports avec
lequel nous avons déjà eu l'occasion
d'évoquer en partie là la question des
transports ferroviaires
mais nous souhaitions évidemment pouvoir
aller plus avant et rient plus loin avec
vous sur sur cette question qui
évidemment nous préoccupe beaucoup est
au coeur des travaux de notre commission
nous avons d'ailleurs installé un groupe
de suivi avec des références sur cette
question et tout à l'heure vous aurez
l'occasion d'entendre notamment didier
mandelli qui vous interpellera sûrement
sur un certain nombre de deux sujets la
situation sanitaire a évidemment conduit
votre groupe à devoir s'adapter aussi
rapidement que profondément vous allez
dû diminuer de manière drastique l'offre
de transport non pas comme ce sera le
cas pour s'adapter à la demande mais
pour s'adapter à des nécessités
impérieuses fixés par l'état en termes
de sécurité sanitaire aujourd'hui je
crois que ce sont seulement 7 % des tgv
15 % des ter circulent mais le chiffre
est encore plus réduit et quand on prend
en compte le nombre de voyageurs et le
décret tout à l'heure sur la question du
fret vous avez dû continuer à assurer
l'approvisionnement du pays et c'est
pour ça que malgré la crise le volume de
fret s'est maintenue à un niveau
relativement important que le crac
soissons 60% des trains prévus au plan
de transport qui fonctionne aujourd'hui
en matière de frais alors toutes ces
modifications ont rendu nécessaire le
fait que vous adaptiez profondément le
mode de fonctionnement de notre
entreprise et vous en parlera
certainement avec bien sûr la nécessité
d'assurer
la protection de vos salariés cette
réorganisation est là aussi vous êtes
surtout des attaques ution économiques
et financières qui sont importantes pour
votre groupe pour le ferai bien sûr qui
est déjà dans une situation dont on
connaît tous la tragédie t mais au delà
je crois pour l'ensemble du groupe qui
subit de plein fouet cette citation de
cette situation qui après avoir subi les
conséquences de la grève aujourd'hui ce
subit les conséquences de cette de cette
pandémie et c'est vrai que nous sommes
relativement inquiet par rapport à la
situation du groupe par rapport à ses
résultats par rapport à sa trajectoire
financière par rapport aussi aux
investissements qu'il doit réaliser jean
baptiste le départ et c'est sans doute à
liart cheese et les investissements qui
sont prévues et nous imaginer les
inquiétudes que l'on peut avoir
notamment sur l'avenir des petites
lignes et on se pose aussi la question
de savoir si dans ce contexte dans ce
climat la question de l'ouverture à la
concurrence n'est pas système remise en
cause en tout cas retarder ou en tout
cas plus plus difficile que prévu à
l'origine
au-delà de ces sujets d'actualité nous
nous aimerions vous entendre sur les
résidences hurle après la presle après
11 mai comment remet en service des
lignes qui ont été à l'arrêt pendant
deux mois faire de l'infrastructure
matérielle notamment et comment on fait
en sorte que les gestes barrière
apparemment et très certainement il
faudra continuer à mettre en oeuvre
pendant de longs mois comment on met en
oeuvre ces gestes barrières dans les
transports de voyageurs et avec quelles
conséquences pour vous en terme
d'organisation et en termes financiers
voilà monsieur près dans farandou
quelques éléments que je voulais mettre
sur la table en début de cette audition
je vais bien sûr vous laisser la parole
pour un propos liminaire et ensuite je
donne ma parole à mes collègues qui ont
déjà fait savoir qu'ils souhaitaient
vous interrogez ainsi que les présidents
de nofilia à vous messieurs ferrand vous
savez m
merci à ce président
merci beaucoup de m'accueillir en
quelque sorte dans la vidéo auprès de
votre commission
je salue aussi bien sur le rapporteur de
la commission et tous les membres de la
condition ultime en gp lui de deux types
un petit concours introductif pour mon
départ et je suis accompagné aussi de 2
pc en famille chez htc voyageurs qui
pourra développer les aspects que vous
avez sur l'offre voyageurs et puis aussi
frédéric de l'ordre le président de
notre fait
il a aussi souligné la question du fret
qui est très présent pendant la crise
pour autant nous savons tous qu'il ya
des sujets de fond qui se posent sur
l'activité fret ferroviaire donc
s'apprécier intéressants qui sont
incapables de détailler et ses analyses
et ses propositions mon premier propos
ça sera la réaction de la sncf pendant
la crise je crois ce qui nous a guidé
c'est la mobilisation de l'entreprise
publique au service des français
je crois que c'est dans ces conditions
là qu'on retrouve l'essence même de ce
qui est dans une grande entreprise de
service public
nous nous sommes mobilisés avec tous les
cheminots à la fois pour assurer le
service essentiels demandé par le pays
pour les voyageurs comme pour le fret
nous allons bien sûr intégrer les
consignes de protection protection des
français de protection sanitaire et puis
bien sûr en ayant toujours en tête la
protection de mes salariés de
non-salariés les cheminots tout en étant
en première ligne de la deuxième ligne
pour aller faire tourner des trains il
faut sortir il faut sortir de chez soi
on a bien sûr des gens confinait
légendes et des fonctions support son
sens télétravail mais on a aussi
beaucoup de cheminots plusieurs milliers
de cheminots qui sortent dans les poses
aiguillages qui sont dans les quatre
autres qui sortent dans l'est dans les
chantiers on a aussi des chantiers qui
sont poursuivies dans les ateliers de
maintenance ont fait on a aussi tout c
est donc cette force industrielle de la
sncf qui ne savaient pas arrêté qui ne
s'arrête pas pendant pendant le pendant
cette recette celle de reprise on a
réagi très vite en mettant en place dès
les premiers jours une
une task force excusez-moi d'anglicismes
a fait une force de très haut niveau qui
est en relation et pouvoirs publics
puisque nous avons bien sûr nous sommes
inscrits dans la dans les orientations
données par les pouvoirs publics en
matière sanitaire donc respectons
strictement et nous avons amplifié dans
les outils d'information sur les gestes
barrières à la fois pour notre propre
personnel mais aussi pour les voyageurs
nous avons 18 diffuser beaucoup de
messages dans les premiers jours où il
fallait faire la promotion des
gestes-barrières des gestes qui sauvent
que j'allais venir pendant cette période
de deux virus
le plan de transport a été
considérablement abaissé récemment c'est
une notion d' un peu de marche
d'escalier que nous avons descendu au
fur et à mesure que la situation
sanitaire du pays
suture si c'est en quelque sorte et
christophe fenice d'ailleurs m'a aidé à
organiser cette cette réduction de
l'offre
nous l'avons fait progressivement nous
l'avons fait bien sûr en liaison avec
les autorités organisatrices de quitter
dans les régions en province et ils ne
feront mobilité à vis de la france
on peut souligner la qualité des
relations je crois qu'ils se sont
installés des frais des contacts
fréquents à la fois mais sur région par
région avec nos directions régionales
donc aussi souligner aussi l'action de
francs delacroix qui à la fois directeur
des ter l'autre six directeurs
territoire nous avons le souci depuis le
début de la mort c'est à pile approche
centralisée de la crise pour coordonner
l'action des 7 cf
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
mais aussi d'avoir des relais locaux des
relais régionaux pour ajuster très
finement notre offre et notre action
région par région
je crois qu'on a à peu près réussi à le
faire on est en ce moment ainsi que le
réunion hebdomadaire avec les dix
présidents transport et j'ai moi-même
plus appelé plusieurs fois les
présidents les jours pour ajuster nos
visions respectives au fur et à mesure
nous avons progressivement calais calais
cette offre qui maintenant à peu près
arrivé l'espèce d'étiage donc on le
rappelle l'ofs tgv est très très basse
on n'a que 40 tgv par jour qui circulent
alors que d'habitude c'est entre 600 et
700 donc on mois
tgv considérant réduite ce qui est
logique par rapport au confinement
le confinement et à la demande des
pouvoirs publics que les clés que les
gens ne se déplacent pas partout dans le
territoire
donc il ya une grande cohérence par
rapport à cette offre ni mal mais elle
est toujours là parce que je crois que
c'est important d'assurer le lien
territorial au plan national il peut y
avoir aussi quelques personnes qui ont
besoin d'aller aider leurs parents ainsi
qu'à l'autre donc j'ai tenu et les
pouvoirs publics en ont été d'accord à
maintenir un flux normal d'autres tgv
nord orapi ensuite sur les sur les
terrains on est autour de qu'est ce
qu'on semble comme vous l'êtes du
président donc c'est vraiment une
logique de risque travail a
essentiellement donc ça fonctionne et
sur l'île de france c'est pareil on est
à peu près à 20 25 % d'offres en mythe
de france sur l'origine c'est là où le
nombre de personnes à transporter la
plus importante des deux centres
névralgiques qui sont réjouis de france
et au delà des soignants mais évidemment
qui sont le coeur de cible et nous avons
dû ajuster les horaires ou des trains ou
des cartes parfois nous en complément
nous avons vraiment centré sur les
besoins premiers les personnels
soignants dans les hôpitaux en
particulier avec des prix des services
décalé mais on a aussi on n'oublie pas
aller les soldats de la 2e ligne opodo
partie en quelque sorte avec tous ces
personnels dont nous avons besoin pour
assurer le fonctionnement de leur pays
sur le fret je pense que frédéric y
reviendra nous avons fait davantage le
fret nous avons à peu près 60 65 % des
trains de fret qui circulent par rapport
à une offre une offre habituelle donc
ces deux notions de il ya d'abord les
très vite on voit absolument vitaux
fonctionnement stratégie du pays ça peut
étonner des carburants par exemple qu'on
a besoin
ça peut être du chlore pour les pour les
traitements des onze essais aux toutous
l'alimentaire bien sûr aussi mais on a
eu aussi le souci de favoriser le
maintien de l'activité économique du
pays
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est allé un peu
au delà du strict retour d'un point de
vue
le lire absolument nécessaire en état
les impurs de là à la demande de nos
clients d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on traite à peu près
l'essentiel la demande de nos clients
on a quelques clients qui souffrait je
pense à arcelor ou les roues là où la
sidérurgie de manière plus générale où
les commandes de production d'acier au
bcd c'est d'ailleurs lié à la saison de
capture et de clients que soit votre
style l'automobile aussi souffrent
beaucoup en transportant d'habitude par
l autre 8 donc en gros on fait face
quasiment à l'essentiel de la demande
s'est fait aider nous ont vraiment un
acteur important de la conduite et et
l'économie du pays on peut citer les ans
des céréales peut-être que par mini
parmi vous il ya des sénateurs qui
viennent des zones céréalières de nous
avons joué un rôle majeur pour écouler
des céréales stockées dans les silos
vers les ports pour la conservation et
erre dans les grands brûlés par exemple
on fabriquer de la farine
il est important de vider dessine aussi
donc à la recoleta riz les céréales il
sait plus où mettre la récolte donc
c'est absolument jindal d'écouler les
stocks dans les silos et vraiment je
pense que nous avons été exemplaires du
gauche il souligné on ne fait pas
souvent parce qu'on les voit pas le
l'action de nos collègues sncf région
notamment les postes d'aiguillage qui
puisque notamment pour les céréales il
faut aller les chercher dans les
campagnes les céréaliers sont pas
installés en centre-ville et donc qu'ils
vont ouvrir des petits points
d'aiguillage et des lignes capillaire
qui permet d'aller chercher les
marchandises au plus près de l'ordre de
leur production donc le frepe démontre
qu'il est un acteur majeur de l'économie
du pays
j'ai inversé particulièrement dans les
cales compliqué que les choses peut-être
se voit se voit davantage un point que
vous avez soulevé aussi c'est la
protection sanitaire de nos personnels
bien sûr le vague il est bien évidemment
les mesures au roi eelv ont été prises
dans le temps mais l'application stricte
des gestes-barrières nous avons rédiger
des fiches métiers
nous avons revu les fiches métiers
normale entre guillemets pour les
adapter aux circonstances sanitaire du
comique 19 nous allons aussi le courage
de fermer des services notamment qu'il
n'était pas indispensable je pense aux
services de vente aux guichets
parce que là avec des idées on avait au
fil du temps enlevez les hygiaphone à
les fameuses afone étaient des sûretés
année donc il n'y avait pas de barrière
fils
ic entre nos personnels de vente et la
clientèle donc nous est apparu plus
sûres
finalement et pour les clients et pour
nos salariés de d'arrêter la vente au
guichet sur le contrôle des trains c'est
pareil nous avons recentré l'action des
contrôleurs sur la réaction de sécurité
indispensables à la mise en circulation
des trains voilà quelques exemples où
nous avons pris des décisions radicales
pour moins exposée aux personnels et
quand on les combine bien sûr avec la
réduction drastique de l'offre
on voit bien qu'on a eu pour effet
d'exploser moins de moyens de cheminots
on risque on risque sanitaire sur l'
usage des masques
je pense peut-être un sujet sur lequel
on reviendra peut-être pour rappeler
alors c'est des choses qui sont pas
conduit on n'a pas fait trop de
publicité là dessus nous avions sncf
stocks de précaution contrairement à
peut-être à d'autres entreprises sncf
était plus fourmis que cigales et nous
avions constitué un stock stratégique de
masquer des sur ce soit sur la stratégie
de masques ou sous contrôle de l'état
dès le début de la crise nous l'avons
conservé physiquement mais avec un
contrôle strict de l'état l'état nous a
demandé quand même de donner tous les
masques ffp2 donné l'état pour que
l'établissent approvisionner les
hôpitaux
donc ça les masques ffp2 la sncf sont
partis très vite dans le circuit et on
peut le comprendre bien évidemment des
basques à destination des soignants et
nous avons gardé un stock de masques
chirurgicaux à disposition entre
parenthèses d'ailleurs nous avons donné
une partie de ces masques à la ratp qui
avait peut-être pas eu la même
précaution que nous en se dotant de
masques et depuis le début nous avons
une utilisation sous contrôle de l'état
et validation et a ténu au départ que
nous avons peu amplifié au fil du temps
sur les masques nous avons dû gérer bien
sûr le le risque pour les personnels en
contact avec des clients qui ont été
soumis d'abord aux risques sanitaires et
kiala aux médias qui ont installé le
risque très important autour de ce virus
donc il fallait les sécuriser en quelque
sorte
donc nous avons mis en place un système
de quitte donc chaque chaque contrôleur
chaque agents de la surveillance
générale
sûreté ferroviaire dont on a bien besoin
aussi dans cette période et les
conducteurs qui sont seuls à bord des
trains et qui peuvent intervenir parfois
partie occupée par les voyageurs
nous avons doté de deux masques chacun
notation individuelle qui leur
permettait de se protéger si les
circonstances que le demandait nous
avons aussi élargi ce stock de masques à
des collectifs dont il ya les stocks de
précaution dans des collectifs de bejar
par exemple de coquillages et puis plus
récemment quand on l'a vu monter aussi
les problèmes de 2,2 respect les gestes
barrière nous avons doté d'un personnel
de maintenance à la fois des matériels
roulants et de la voix de masques à
titre plus individuel puisque les dieux
étaient confinés dans les poses
aiguillages et à la fois ne pouvez pas
toujours mais de tenir une distance
suffisante entre les salariés
donc nous allons fin mars élargit ses de
ses dotations de la sq voilà le nom mais
non doctrine qui a évolué au fil du
temps des sur une nouvelle nous avons
comme les pouvoirs publics évoluer notre
positifs ont évolué au fur et à mesure
je voulais aussi pointé le dialogue les
syndicats qui a été de qualité c'est pas
toujours sympa et c'est vous le savez
peut-être qu'on y voit aussi peut-être
le bénéfice de relation sociale connaît
plus amélioré dans l'entreprise ce
paradoxe sur la conduite autour des
retraites mais le fond de respect mutuel
est installé les coûts de mutuelle et
nous avons déçu retravailler avec en
guest syndicales sur ces règles de
protection devant jouer la transparence
totale puisque nous avons une conférence
sanitaire interne au sein de la sncf
nous faisons le point sanitaire des
cheminots malade et nous avons associé
par exemple un représentant des
syndicats à ces conférences sanitaires
dont qu'ils ont accès à toute
l'information en toute transparence
voilà donc le fait que à la fois montrer
notre sérieux dans l'est dans les règles
de protection dont seuls deux salariés
et le fait de jouer la transparence nous
a permis de réduire le risque de
normalement de norme allemande et ses
sicav de droit de retrait nous avons
bien quelques petits droit de retrait
sporadiques à droite à gauche mais
franchement là c'est sous contrôle
ils n'auront pas eu à gérer les droits
de retrait massif sur pénaliser
lourdement le
mise en place du service 107,01 yens
pourvu que ça dure il est évident pour
lui que ça dure et d'ailleurs
commencerons à travailler avec eux sur
les conditions de reprises parce qu'il
faudra les associer à la manière de
d'augmenter considérablement le nombre
de trains le serons amenés à produire à
partir du 11 mai qui la date cible qui a
été indiqué par le président la
république et sur laquelle tout ce
travail et je regarde les messages que
je voulais vous donner peut-être vous
dire qu'au delà de cet effort de
participations directes plan de
transport en situations sanitaires
dégradés
il ya eu les plus de la sncf le plus
spectaculaire céder sur les tgv
sanitaires c'est une idée verts de
christophe mani cher il faut rendre à
césar danser le président finish et qui
a eu cette idée là elle est formidable
elle ne remplit de fierté les cheminots
alors se connaissent tous petits buy aux
grandes chaînes salutaire mais c'est
vrai que là c'est une contribution
beaucoup plus direct à l'effort
sanitaires du pays c'est beaucoup de
travail
ces deux ou trois jours de préparation
pour équiper les trains aux transports
sanitaires salle avait des petits
hôpitaux et les trains devaient des peas
hôpitaux avec deux de l'air comprimé qui
a embarqué à bord des installations
électriques question pour faire marcher
tous les appareils nécessaires là au
maintien des malades qui sont embarqués
dans c'est un gros travail aussi de
sécurisation la circulation est sûr
c'est qu'elles n'ont pas droit à la
parole erreur et tout leur trajet est
très surveillée pour être sûr à 100%
qu'ils arriveront à destination dans les
meilleures conditions
c'est vrai que d'un petit but cherté
cheminote de participer plus directement
à l'effort sanitaires au delà le ça
aussi je crois que j'ai été un des
premiers à être le premier à proposer à
la réserve d'airé service au sénat et
celle de se mettre à disposition lulu du
plan résilience monté par l'état nous
avons 500 réservistes qui sont qui ont
été mis à disposition de la delà de la
défense pour donner un coup de main dans
le cas du plan résilience à l'étang du
pays
aussi beaucoup de générosité de la part
des cheminots la fondation sncf sncf
immobilier fait des tas de choses à
faire voilà tout l'été les forces de la
scène ces efforts ont le souci de faire
plus
encore que de faire rouler des trains
dans cette période ces périodes
difficiles les territoires jamais parlé
je répondrai à inventer sur l'aspect
économique
alors oui nous allons subir de longs de
perse est encore trop tôt pour les
chiffrer elles sont le monde elles sont
lourdes elles sont considérables on
commence bien sûr déjà anticipé et les
sujets sur les sujets de trésorerie et
sur les sujets de d'économie post crise
sur la trésorerie la sncf est solide
trésorerie court terme que nous sommes
une entreprise solide bon pour autant en
faire attention à ces sujets trésorerie
sans panique s'en sort sans sans crainte
excessive mais cette 7e rang je rassure
tout le monde nous paierons les salaires
nous plaire aux fournisseurs sont
d'ailleurs attention aux petites
entreprises à notre attention a pas joué
à les délais de paiement pour thoune
automne ils sont nés c'est en général
mais sur les petites entreprises en
particulier pour autant nous allons sur
les marchés pour lever pour lever de la
ressource
nous l'avons fait récemment la semaine
dernière nous avons levé un milliard
deux cent cinquante millions de doro
avait décrit de bones d'ailleurs puisque
nous avions cette possibilité de le
faire donc une évidence tourner vers le
vers le développement durable
voilà donc nous serons prudents ben
seront actifs mais sans paniquer sncf
tiendra d'un second plan financier même
si c'est une année particulière
nous n'ouvrons au delà des financements
dormons prévu notamment pour financer
des investissements de la sncf c'est
hautement importante est sûre nous
aurons bien sûr à rajouter les décalages
de rentrée que nous allons enregistrer
avec cette activité très réduite pendant
quelques mois et quelques mois de ce que
dureront que bureau aura ce ce
confinement le fret alors le fret je
vais vite puisque frédérique deloffre
d'être déportée en répondant à nos
questions
bon le vrai que c'est un souci
préoccupations économiques on savait que
la situation du fret est compliqué une
société anonyme a été créé en début
d'année tant qu'à elle elle est notée de
fonds propres de sang sont des millions
de fonds propres
elle peut tenir quelque temps mais au
fond la condition que j'ai je serai
course et
si on veut que le fret ferroviaire se
porte bien dans le pays et au delà de la
seule sncf il ya d'autres opérateurs
privés qui exploite du fret ferroviaire
au pays il faut qu'elle soit aidée comme
d'autres pays européens l'ont fait nous
pensons que le maintien et le
développement de préférons pierre est
souhaitable et possible et souhaitable
ce pays
mais à l'instar de ce qui a été fait
dans d'autres pays européens il faut que
les systèmes dell qui se met en place
on est une vraie perspective une vraie
durabilité on transporte de frais voilà
donc les 7 principes dead avant d'aller
encore plus importants en sortie de
crise parce que bien évidemment même si
le faisons rouler des trains
on voit bien que l'activité économique
sera compliqué dans notre pays
à la sortie de cette grève voilà pour
conclure je redirai que la sncf prend
toute sa place dans l'histoire du pays
en ce moment pendant la crise bien
évidemment je peux me dire les cheminots
sont très engagés on retrouve vraiment
ces valeurs confort de l'appartenance et
de conviction un service public un grand
service public français au service des
français au service des territoires
et sur la paix je souhaite qu'il soit
prolongé au delà de la crise parce qu'au
fond je pense que aussi bien en fred
quand voyageurs le ferroviaire et les cd
r et d'autres acteurs du ferroviaire
la solution pour une mobilité à la fois
durables bien évidemment au service des
territoires
mais aussi de faux billets mobilité
salutaire parce que quand on compare
avec la voiture
on peut contrôler et réguler les gens
qui prennent le train
on ne peut pas contrôler les gens qui
prennent la voiture on l'a vu encore
avec l'étiquette de débrider le train
est quelque chose de réguler l'usagé de
la voiture dans l'est beaucoup moins
et donc pour moi le train doit être la
solution d'une mobilité durable et
sanitaires voilà les points que je
voulais c'était comme dans des
productions et ses démentis mêlant que
je répondrai aux questions que vous
souhaiteriez vous me posez avec l'aide
du président de l'homme et du président
qualifié merci beaucoup pour votre
écoute bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
président je suis un petit peu resté à
ce stade sur ma faim sur la près mais je
pense que vous à l'occasion d'y revenir
lors des réponses aux questions qui vont
vous être posée
j'ai déjà une quinzaine de sénateurs ont
demandé à s'exprimer et donc je vais
tout de suite donné la parole d'un dj et
magali monsieur morelli mantois rangs
didier mandelli avoir peut-être
sédiments ne montant pas je vais tout de
suite donné la parole à alain fouché
on attendait monsieur payet n'a cassé
allez-y monsieur touchés monsieur le
président bonjour bon j'ai pu comprendre
qu'une partie mais j'ai entendu ce qui
concerne le fret le fret c'est un peu
comme l'arlésienne et on en parle
beaucoup dans ce pays depuis des années
bon pour ma part c'est pas la sncf qui
est responsable
je pense que ce sont les différents
gouvernements les différents ministres
des transports quelques toiles d'une
aurore ils ont le fitm années d'autres
etc de tous horizons qui n'ont pas su
donner les instructions de suffisante à
l'assiette et les moyens pour mettre en
route le fret
j'ai entendu ce que vous disiez monsieur
le président qu'il fallait dès le fret
pour que cela réussisse la part
essentielle la question je voulais vous
poser c'est le fret s'est effectivement
baisse beaucoup par rapport aux pays
voisins
est ce que cette concurrence étrangère
ne risque pas de vous faire perdre un
certain nombre de clients et mallet et
en particulier des gros clients
voilà ma question c'est trop merci
beaucoup n'hésitent j'entre in oui je
vais répondre d'être une réponse à deux
voix avec frédéric de l'homme qui doit
intervenir rapidement
je crois qu'il faut que l'on parle pas
pour autant pour laisser le temps à tout
le monde de poser les questions en
termes de concurrence
honnêtement c'est pas mes collègues
occupe le plus c'est les séances
la route est un concurrent redoutable
qui a pris l'essentiel de la protection
des pratiques en europe
quand on rajoute en plus cela vous avez
raison c'est que sur le plan routier le
le swap et le pavillon français les
routiers français il a moins en moins il
ya de plus en plus de transporteurs
routiers des pays de l'est par exemple
qui sont très présents dans le pays avec
des réglementations européennes
qui facilite le fait que des conducteurs
venant des pistes est resté plus de
trois semaines sur le territoire
donc c'est une forme de concurrence
redoutable il faut reconnaître que le
fret routier très efficaces s'ils sont
pertinents
une souplesse bien sûr que le verrou me
revient pas ils ont des goûts assez bas
et donc c'est le concurrent principal et
ils ont pris l'essentiel du marché
pensent que la route avec klan 85 96 %
des parts de marché et je pense qu'un
sujet c'est un sujet aussi de l'intérêt
général quand on voit la pollution
produite par les camions on pense à
laval avait les larmes par exemple qui
souffrent les particules et délits par
les camions qui font lé transit entre la
france et l'italie
quand on pense aux points de congestion
sur nos autoroutes qui n'a pas souffert
de voir une fille doit quasiment occupé
par départ des trains camions
je pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet
d'intérêt général a rééquilibré en
partie en partie les trafics de la route
vers le train donc c'est vraiment ça ce
qu'il faut faire
il ya au niveau européen une ambition de
doubler la part de marché du lieu du 13
je pense que là il faut absolument qu'on
rééquilibre les choses dit c'est un
sujet d'intérêt général me semble-t-il
je veux donner la mort de frédéric si de
compléter le président delor vin va
peut-être complété en quelques mots
comment ils voient cette question de la
concurrence et des comment pourrais
citron pour développer le fret dans leur
pays peut-être aussi mettre d'accord
prier en bref merci aujourd'hui à
paroles offrir de l'homme
l'encré ou ceux de leurs malles hésite
oui merci monsieur le président m
oui alors en complément ce que je
pourrais dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui fret
et cinq siècles ou pas seule en france à
transporter les marchandises par le rail
nous représentons par fred 55 % du
volume mais à l'intérêt de ce volume
comme l'a dit le président farandou il y
a une part importante dont le seul
concurrent et la route et là on est face
à un choix intermodal plutôt qu'un choix
de concurrence intra modal les chiffres
sont assez rude a effectivement en
trente ans le transport routier en
france a été multiplié par deux et demi
celui sous pavillon étranger par dix
quand dans le même temps le transport
ferroviaire de marchandises a utilisé
par deux ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la
part de marché du rail tout transporteur
confondues et de 9% en france alors que
la moyenne en europe et de 18 % voire
même 30% en autriche et en suisse
donc la question du retour des
marchandises sur le rail voit toute
utilité pendant cette crise passe par un
meilleur équilibrage entre la route et
le rail faut pas les opposer car la
route contribuer à amener des
marchandises aux rails notamment pour le
transport combiné
mais si on veut bien prendre en compte
le coût des externalités éviter c'est à
dire le coût de la tonne de co2 émise le
coût des accidents
le coût pour la santé des personnes et
des morts prématurées par pollution en
europe
il y a un enjeu qui se chiffre à environ
9 milliards d'euros sur dix ans de coude
externalités qui pourraient être évités
si on doubler la part de marché du rail
pour le transport de marchandises en
france 9 milliard d'euros donc la
question va se poser en termes de
méthode d'incitation qui accompagneront
les efforts de productivité des
entreprises ferroviaires nous en avons
d'autre part il faut moderniser le train
il faudra moderniser aussi le réseau
pour le le réseau fret mais il ya
sûrement une question de politique
publique va se poser en matière de
soutien ou transfert modal voilà mais je
pourrais répondre plus en plus en détail
si vous le souhaitez un peu merci merci
et je crois qu on va pouvoir donner la
parole cette fois didier mandelli il dit
mon délit monsieur mans délit on est con
les retrouver les connexions
avec la vendée n'est pas satisfaisante
apparemment bon frédéric marchand
oui bonjour monsieur le président
bonjour messieurs les présidents la
connexion avec le nord est meilleure
mais c'est normal puisque nous avons à
hélène n'est ce pas monsieur président
farandou un excellent technicentre que
nous avions inauguré ensemble alors
justement s'agissant des technicentres
n'avait pas annoncé la page de publicité
là monsieur la saison pour profitons-en
profitons-en puisque centralisée pour
couper la parole simplement monsieur
verdoux puisqu'on évoque les
technicentres peut-être un focus sur
l'activité aujourd'hui dans ces
techniques sentent qu'ils sont des
outils d'excellence pour la sncf un
deuxième sujet qui va regrouper ce qui a
été dit par mon collègue fouchier sur le
fret
puisque nous avons eu ce matin avec
didier mandelli une audition de la
phrase où on revient qui effectivement
s'agissant du fret bon nombre
d'interlocuteurs évoque la nécessité de
mettre en place un véritable plan
marshall du fret
puisque on se rend compte aujourd'hui de
la nécessité en cette période est sans
doute de la nécessité de demain ça a été
dit et que ça recoupe aussi finalement
les conclusions quand on écoute ce qui
est dit parlement de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat de différents
films donc finalement l'avenir et aux
modes de transports alternatifs et
notamment aux rails donc avec notamment
vous l'avez dit une nécessité de porter
des financements publics en termes de
rénovation de manière un peu plus
conséquente est alors un dernier sujet
qui m'intéresse c'est très égoïstement
puisque pour rallier l'île à paris
j'utilise régulièrement le train
s'agissant du jour d'après en matière de
mesure de distanciation social dans un
wagon comme envisagé aussi les choses
puisque je pense qu'on a toujours une
appréhension de la part de celles et
ceux qui vous mentent et l'entrain
merci beaucoup donc merci d'avoir évacué
le jour d'après effectivement j'aimerais
bien qu'on puisse en temps de présence à
rendre très bien merci d'écouter ces
derniers que je vais prendre vos
questions c'est vrai quand on s'était
croisé à élèves dans un magnifique
atelier tout neuf qui symbolise le
renouveau de la sncf
d'or et le caractère industriel sncf qui
parfois méconnus et moins visibles les
grands ateliers sont sont absolument
nécessaires sur la capacité de montée
par transport on a un sujet de
maintenance du parc
le parti élus en particulier quand je
vous disais que il n'ya que 7 % des tgv
qui roule ça veut dire qu'il ya
énormément de rames tgv qui sont garées
on a eu le souci de l'aider soulès soul
d'ailleurs la supervision de présence
inquiète on est le souci de les aider
les gars et on a fait ça car est bonne
et à les reconnaître certain nombre de
mesures de précaution que nous prenons
comme ici mobilisons pour ont dans leur
utilisation plus facile
voilà donc tout ça était furent bonnes
on a fait attention à être
précautionneux avait avec des tas de
laurent tgv est et c'est vrai que par
rapport à la perspective indiqué par le
président la république le 11 mai nous
allons accroître la maintenance des
rames landou préparer à redémarrer
l'exploitation et c'est peut-être le
premier métier que nous allons
intensifier et bien c'est serré te lance
donc nous allons préparer les conditions
dans lesquelles nous allons rappeler
davantage de cheminots dans les ateliers
pour faire des opérations de maintenance
qui ont été mises de côté on n'a fait
que la que la maintenance strictement
nécessaire il ya des opérations plus
importantes qu'il faut faire il ya aussi
les opérations d'ailleurs de préparation
des conditions d'exploitation l'été en
adressant de btan sur qui doit être
faite sur le matériel pour non seulement
relancé notre entre à partir de de la
libert et nous l'espérons
et puis progressivement se préparer à
une danse normal que le site sont plutôt
au début de l'été je termine ce jour
d'après d'ailleurs et je jouerai sur le
srec ensuite alors le jour d'après nous
le préparons bien sûr il ya la première
idc qui sera progressive parce que le
nom d'après sera progressif donc en
matière de télé mais nous allons avoir
une remontée progressive de l'offre qui
est cherchera à d'ailleurs a accolé à la
demande donc des salons d essayer
d'estimer qu'elle sera quelle sera la
demande à partir quand on le vit verrons
plus clair sur les consignes sanitaires
que le gouvernement mettra en place pour
la pour le dégonflement partiel ou le
continent allait au tibet les mots qu'on
veut pas partir du 11 mai puisque pour
le moment c'est le 11 mai qu'est la date
bhl nous allons calais calais l'offre
que nous mettrons en place
ça nous permettra aussi de ronde et leur
tour leur à la relance dont nous aurons
une reprise progressive avec peut-être
le par rapport à l'offre actuelle
doublement à peu près de l'autre dans
les premières semaines
ensuite un autre palier autour d'un tgv
sur deux pendant un mois environ
et puis on espère arriver à 100 % des
tgv au début de l'été en tout cas c'est
le plan de route que nous nous fixons
c'est une première estimation pour nous
organiser nous adapterons cesser par
l'escalier par le haut sous pli en
fonction de la réalité de la demande et
de la et de la rigueur des consignes
sanitaires sur les consignes sanitaires
alors devant nous les appliquerons très
strictement
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui dans les tgv
qui roule nous appliquons la
distanciation sanitaire embêtant
accidents passés gestion 2 dans les tgv
donc ça nous appliquons ça avec les
règles de réservation nous nous
interrogeons sur la poursuite de cette
règle pourquoi parce que d'abord elle
est très handicapante duo capacitaire en
ce prix de la moitié des capacités donc
séquelles très pénalisant en matière de
l'efficacité du plan de transport
proposons et puis deuxièmement je crois
qu'il faut être clair la dimension
économique aussi doit être de commencer
notre occupation et vous savez que le
point mort et le tgv c'est environ 60 %
d'occupation
ça veut dire que tu en connais pas sur
son intention d' occupation nous perdons
de l'argent à chaque tgv qui circulent
alors nous l'accepterons bien sûr
reconduit voilà c'est dit que ce genre
de préoccupations ne rentre pas de
compte à la situation actuelle
mais quand on se projette sur les mois
qui viennent je pense que la dimension
économique doit commencer à rentrer
aussi dans nos perspectives et c'est la
raison pour laquelle notre position est
assez clair nous souhaiterions
conditionnelle parce que ce n'est pas
nous qui pourront décider cet orient que
les pouvoirs publics demandent comme ça
d'ailleurs été un peu évoquée par le
président de la république que les
passagers ferroviaires porte un masque
pour pouvoir utiliser les moyens de
transports ferroviaires et nous
souhaiterions que cette règle soit soit
d'application obligatoire est clair donc
il faut porter un masque pour reprendre
le train à la fois dans les tgv
d'ailleurs corde pour les transports de
la vie quotidienne où il est encore plus
dur de maintenir la règle de
distanciation et que dès lors si le
basket est obligatoire nous pensons
alors il faudra d'avis médical pour le
confirmer
nous pensons que comme que dans ce cas
là nous pourrions lever la règle de
distanciation et donc revenir à une
occupation plus classique de l'eau tgv
voilà ça c'est pour le jour d'après en
tout cas en termes de modalités donc une
reprise progressive
on va dire autour de 10 9% puis 50% puis
100 % à l'été ça c'est l'exploit que
nous avons en matière de remontée du
trafic pour les tgv pour les trains de
la vie quotidienne nous pensons
redémarrer très vite à 50% pour les ter
comme pour l'île de france et ensuite
s'adapter à la demande au fur et à
mesure que que le nombre de de deux
français héros devant pour aller
travailler en particulier remporterait
ça c'est un peu les perspectives en
matière d'offre et de trafic
et puis sur l' usage du travail du
masque obligatoire pour nous permettre
de de lever ou de ledger distanciation
qui nous paraissent très très compliquée
à appliquer on pourrait renforcer les
dispositifs aussi avec des dispositifs
bien sûr le de tic gel lavage de mains
et s'est en fait renforcée aussi
l'application des règles de barrières
pour sécuriser complètement le
dispositif
voilà ce que je peux vous répondre sur
alors quant au fret oui il faut un plan
marshall
il faut un plan marshall pour le fret
j'allais dire pour le proposer avant la
crise on le propose encore plus
puisqu'il ya une notion de prendre lance
aussi qui peut arriver après la crise il
faut effectivement des investissements
pour le frère la fois des
investissements notamment sur le réseau
le réseau a besoin d'être adapté au fret
donc là il ya du boulot à faire sur les
mois de service sur les chantiers triage
sur les itinéraires fred aussi qu'il
faut qu'il faut mettre en place pour que
le fret soit poète est attisée par les
trains voyageurs par exemple donc il ya
des choses à faire en matière
d'infrastructures
et puis il faut pas se le cacher il ya
aussi une dimension fonctionnement il
faut par un système d'incitations aux
entreprises faire en sorte que plus de
marchandises soit sur les travées pas
dans les camions c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'aide au wagon isolé par exemple l'aide
à la presse pour le container donc il ya
des choses effectivement à prévoir pour
encourager les entreprises à davantage
utiliser le train pour transporter leurs
lors leurs marchandises
merci beaucoup je pense que on a
peut-être une chance d'avoir monsieur le
mans délit monsieur mans délit est un
délit l'arlésienne de cette audition
monsieur mandé dit une fois deux fois
trois fois
madame à ça si madame à ça si les we
président vous m'entendez très bien
bonjour depuis la seine saint denis qui
souffrent beaucoup
merci au président d'auray pour
l'organisation de cette audition et
merci à vos collaboratrices et
collaborateurs
bonjour j'ai un collègue bonjour
messieurs les présidents
en premier lieu je veux aussi salué le
sens des responsabilités des cheminots
dans tous les corps leur corps de
béquilles pour dans cette épreuve que
notre pays traverse j'ai trois questions
que des rapides un que je projette aussi
dans la sortie progressive du
confinement dès le 11 mai comme la danse
et le président de la république la
première était relative aux questions
sanitaires mais le président tard on
nous a répondu pour une bonne partie aux
questions que j'allais donc je dis
regarde pas je voudrais insister sur le
fret vous savez payer dans mon vrai que
c'est un sujet qui occupe beaucoup et
c'est bien sûr que le fret a été
sacrifié par des politiques des choix
politiques d'hier et d'avant-hier mais
je crois qu'il a été surtout fragilisé
dans votre pays par la baisse d'activité
industrielle alors le ferai tout le
monde s'accordent pour le dire
aujourd'hui est un moyen bien sûr
écologique mais aussi et surtout je
crois que c'est un outil efficace pour
le transport de produits manufacturés
alimentaires ou autres qui sont
nécessaires aux besoins essentiels de
dos de nos concitoyens
je suis ravie monsieur le président
farandou de vous entendre parler de plan
pas
salle pour le fret je crois que c'est
une nécessité absolue
aujourd'hui pour un pays comme le nôtre
et la crise a révélé effectivement que
cette activité devrait être parmi les
activités essentielles dans votre pays
donc j'avais des questions précises mais
est ce qu'il ya des dispositions qui
sont prévus pour sécuriser et donc
relancer au plus vite cette activité
vous avez répondu en partie
dernière question c'est à propos des
infrastructures est ce qu'il ya des
assurances que les aînés ligne qui sont
actuellement fermés car nom circuler
vont pouvoir dans le processus de sortie
du confinement être réouverte et quel
est le plan pour l'entretien de céline
ainsi que pour la maintenance qui n'a
pas été effectué sur les autres lignes
et ce depuis plusieurs semaines voilà je
vous remercie
merci madrasa si monsieur président
farandou
très bientôt je vais je vais reprendre
la question soit de france culture
oui alors d'abord toutes les vitres ont
réouverte évidemment le réseau reprendra
sur l'ensemble des lignes
ça c'est clair à compaq et de le doute
là dessus
ceci étant posé oui c'est compliqué de
faire de la maintenance et des travaux
pendant cette période alors nous en
faisons nous n'avons jamais arrêté d'en
faire et nous avons une forme de logique
de priorité aussi parce que vous avez
peut-être suivi le débat est arrivé
notamment les entreprises qui a l'accord
auquel nous sous traitants les travaux
donc on a vu que tout ce qui est des tpe
ça a été compliqué il ya une espèce de
crise interloqué tp parce qu'on a
constaté que les entreprises et btp
arrêté leur activité
il ya quelques semaines une fois qu'on a
arrêté sur compliqué de mon bon dans la
priorisation que nous avons c'est
d'abord la maintenance nécessaires à
l'exploitation
ça nous en faisons nous allons
intensifier autant qu'on le peut pour
être sûr que par exemple mais nous
soyons capables de reprendre
la circulation des trains donc il est
important que tous que la maintenance
directement liés à l'exploitation des
trains soit assurée il y aura d'ailleurs
des vérifications de sécurité à faire je
pense aux passages à niveau je pense à
100 d'équipements qui devront être
testés pour être sûr que tout fonctionne
et quand on prend 0 risques en matière
de sécurité ferroviaire vers évidente
dans la maintenance de base est la
première priorité
ensuite vous avez la maintenance de
réparation on avait eu alors je pense à
des problèmes de talus on a eu dans
l'est de la france vous souhaitez le tgv
qui a percuté un talus de terre qui
avait glissé sur l'amour a heureusement
pas de mort après cet accident et des
blessés département dont il faut
absolument qu'on retravaille sur les
talus puisque c'est un élément
indispensable à la sécurité ferroviaire
dans les travaux de réparation et de
consolidation devront être menées et
conduit pour être sûr qu'on peut
relancer sans risque on a eu aussi un
problème de talus à porter en ile de
france du côté de sèvres le monde il ya
des maisons qui sont quasiment un
surplomb il faut absolument qu'on sait
que rice et à lui donc ça ça fait partie
des réparations ce que j'appelle les
travaux de réparations indispensables à
la remise en circulation en sécurité de
notre ensuite vous avez des travaux
alors les travaux de des projets de
projets de développement là je vous
cache pas qu'il y aura une forme de
revisite et le priorisation il est à peu
près certain que les deux trois mois de
londres devant dû arrêter les travaux
vont poser à l'évidence des problèmes de
planning
on ne pourra pas les rattraper et
peut-être même cesser ces trois mois
vont s'aggraver vous savez des parce que
quand on fait les travaux ferroviaires
vous avez des fenêtres de tir
interruption pendant les grandes quelque
chose comme ça dont je pense que nous
avons avoir un sujet de reprogrammation
et de planification des grands travaux
avec des retards par rapport aux d'après
lui est dans la question de la
priorisation devra s'opposer avec des
donneurs d'ordre que le donneur d'ordres
soit l'état où les régions auraient
alors un sujet de priorisation et
peut-être peut-être un sujet de
financements
là on en revient aussi à la dimension
économique qui fondera revisiter
l'ensemble des grands projets pour voir
comment ils planifient et comment les
financer comment les priorités voilà
donc ça ça jugé important je n'ai pas
encore la réponse
et il est devant nous et il faudra qu'on
le traite à l'évidence merci monsieur le
président je retiens votre
proposition que nous organisions une
réunion sur la question des risques et
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
ça pourrait évidemment se tenir à huis
clos par rapport aux questions de
confidentialité que vous évoquiez fort
justement il paraîtrait cautionnement
des vies et changer de support
informatique et qu'on puisse peut-être
encore des spermes souvent des lignes
avant de vous entendre et on apprécie de
vous entendre vous êtes fait désirer
donc je laisse la parole m techniques
incompréhensibles pour ce qui me
concerne
merci président bonjour à tous mes
collègues bonjour le président donc je
mets un certain nombre de questions où
les avait en partie aborder les réponses
d'ores et déjà notre intervention et je
suis au travers des questions de mes
collègues maires question elle porte sur
le transport conventionnés vous avez
fait état d' et des relations avec les
havrais mais les régions en particulier
ce qui m'intéresserait cette sorte
qu'elles sont
quel état les discussions à ce jour et
notamment sur la question de la
sécurisation juridique des éventuels
avenants s'agissant d'appel d'offres et
puis je voulais savoir également si des
modifications de tarification des péages
prévu dans les projets document de
référence de réseau sont envisagées à ce
stade sur le fret vous avez en grande
partie répondu sur la reprise des
activités de transport de voyageurs vous
avez des tâches arme de poing ma
question elles portent surtout sur
l'hypothèse d'un déconfinement par
région et dans ce cas la difficulté sera
de d'organiser le tgv comme le père de
lens et notamment sur le plan financier
essentiel à la sncf
est-ce que vous avez d'ores et déjà
travaillé en irak sur des hypothèses de
déconfinement régionales et aux calques
à l'adaptation du réseau tgv sera sera
sans doute compliqué et puis dernier
point qui concerne l'ouverture à la
concurrence le groupe a signé en début
de semaine un accord aurait l'impression
marché espagnol a continué sans 2020
qu'en est il pour notre pays
comment la sncf vous y allez en partie
répondu se prépare-t-elle ou différentes
différentes
ouverture à la concurrence du transport
nation et de voyageurs dans ce contexte
évidemment khirbat un petit peu les
cartes on a eu lieu aujourd'hui même
qu'à candidats potentiels jeter l'épongé
entre guillemets pour la france
est-ce que cncf est d'ores et déjà
prêtes sur pour cette ouverture
compte tenu du contexte merci merci je
me sens un an dour oui tu as l'air ça
fait plaisir de vous retrouver le
rapporteur donc alors sur la relation
avec les autorités organisatrices
écoutez moi je la trouve le temps de
crise ça sert les coudes
voilà je pense qu'on s'est tous
retrouvés entre les les collectivités
territoriales les régions et publiques
comme la sncf au sens de l'intérêt
général je crois que ça nous a
rassemblés nous avons su mener ensemble
la dcri du transport intelligents
avaient d'ailleurs vrai travail de
dentelle j'allais dire région par région
même ligne par ligne puisque nous avons
cherché à bien coller aux besoins de
déplacement des soignants donc on n'a
pas appliqué dépend transport préétabli
c'est ce qu on fire période de grève
là on a vraiment fait du sur mesure dans
chaque territoire sur chaque ligue pour
être sûrs que nous étions capables
d'amener les personnels dans les
hôpitaux en particulier desservies par
ces lignes donc un vrai travail de
collaboration très précise avec avec les
régions sur le filet de l'offre sur le
sujet de contractuels bon sans parler
évidemment mais on n'est pas rentré
encore discussion juridico contre aux
contraintes contractuelles trop trop
serré bon on entend ces sont des sujets
sérieux parce que ça va ça peut ça va
beaucoup jouer aussi sur le sur l'état
de santé de l'entreprise
bon pour le moment ce que je comprends
c'est que les régions dans leur grande
majorité accepterait d'honorer la partie
coucou du service puisque les coûts sont
engagés et coûts engagées sans
engagement donc il y aurait
j'aurais bien volonté de la part des
régions de prendre en charge les coûts
engagés
on a des discussions région par région
et contrat par contrat soit les risques
de recettes des sur les recettes se sont
effondrées
l'état d'esprit général 7e de considérer
ce qui devait arriver comme les départs
de force majeure je pense que personne
ne pouvait prévoir la survenue de cette
crise a été très difficile à anticiper
elle était vraiment irrésistible on le
voit bien on a du mal à résister donc je
pense qu'on est vraiment dans les dents
les attributs de la force majeure dont
vers le gouvernement a déjà utilisé ce
terme me semble-t-il
donc on est à mon avis dans une logique
de force majeure donc je pense que les
que nos obligations de recettes qu entre
nanas sont largement amendé par les
régions qui comprendront le caractère
voilà il dit répressibles et
imprévisible de ce qui nous arrive
pour le moment je considère que les
discussions sont empreintes de beaucoup
bonne volonté de compréhension et
j'espère qu'elle ce qu'elle se
traduiront de la sorte dans les
abonnements ont servi oubliez pas
j'espère que les amenant que nous
passerons traduiront bien la bonne
volonté la compréhension que qui me
semble percevoir on dit chez les
autorités organisatrices sur les appels
d'offres j'y répondrai dans la nasa dans
le volet i dans le volet concurrence sur
les péages
bon c'est encore prématuré aujourd'hui
il ya rien qui a été entrepris sur le
niveau des péages
on peut entendre de ci de là des dix
mois qui s'élève de weedon réajustement
des péages ont souhaité aller péage y
servent à financer le réseau donc le
financement d'un réseau il y avait bien
besoin
donc s'il y avait une forme de réduction
du péage il faudrait trouver une autre
forme de financement voilà si la
réduction des péages se traduit par une
réduction des ressources nécessaires à
la maintenance et aux travaux sur le
réseau ça ce n'est pas une bonne idée
donc on va se tourner à nouveau vers
budget de l'état clair que si les péages
été réduit et on peut comprendre que
certains opérateurs pourraient elles
souhaiter pour leur permettre à démarrer
je pense que le fret par exemple
pourrait peut-être souhaité qu' une
forme de l'adoucissement
des péages attention à ne pas pénaliser
les ressources sur le réseau donc c'est
toujours pareil c'est un peu comme comme
les politiques publiques souvent la
plupart des goûts du public ce que
l'usager ne paie pas c'est le
contribuable qui l'hôtel quoi qui nous
rattrape quel que soit le secteur le
secteur d'activité en matière d'économie
publique
donc voilà donc pourquoi pas je pense
que le sujet n'est pas tabou mais il
faudra aller au bout de la logique
économique qui pourrait qui pourrait
suivre une tentation légitime de
peut-être pour certains de d'adoucir le
coût des péages sur sur le confinement
régionales c'est sûr qu'ils ne seraient
très handicapant pour tgv le tgv par
nature il est plus il est multi régional
il est transrégionale il ya en
particulier la région ile de france
si la région ile-de-france était confiné
en premier ça va si la région
ile-de-france et des confidences dernier
c'est très pénalisant pour le tgv que la
plupart des tgv dans le pays
ils ont de la province à paris et de
paris vers la province donc si la région
ile de france n'est pas accessible
ça sert à rien faire partie en train de
bandeaux pour l'arrêter à poitiers où un
train de nantes pour l'arrêter honore
toujours le faire mais l'intérêt est
très relatif
donc effectivement une stratégie de
déconfinement parole par région par
exemple sauf si elle démarré par la
ville de france serait pénalisant pour
l'activité tva à l'évidence après ça
dépend pas de nous ça dépend de des
pouvoirs publics sanitaires et les
décisions qu'ils prennent donc
respectons évidemment mais tout le monde
comprend que tgv pour être très pénalisé
par une stratégie régionale qui démarre
aurait parlé
les régions les plus éloignées quelque
part considère pas être de france ça
serait la plus mauvaise des stratégies
en ce qui concerne le trafic et le
chiffre d'affaires tgv sur la
concurrence c'est une bonne question
c'est une question à plusieurs niveaux
d'ailleurs philosophique c'est vrai que
pourrait se demander ce qu'on ait donné
la gestion de cette crise
si l'offre ferroviaire a été morcelé par
plusieurs opérateurs
philosophique chacun pourra y réfléchir
bon pour autant à ce stade le calendrier
la concurrence d'ouverture à la
concurrence est maintenu je n'entends
pas de décalage de date
alors certains processus devront être un
peu assouplie parce que c'est pas facile
par exemple j'étais censé envoyer un
courrier à des billets de cheminot dans
la région sud provence alpes côte d'azur
susceptibles d'être conseillé d'être
concerné par des transferts liés à la
mise en concurrence de deux gros lots
ferroviaire par la région sud que
provence et la côte d'azur sur le tr bon
on a estimé que peut-être leafs était
opportun de décaler l'envoi de ces
courriers pour ne pas trop perturber le
camp social cheminots
pour autant l'état donc accepté de
l'employer
mais pour autant la date d'ouverture
sont contents dit à la concurrence est
maintenu donc je ne sens pas à ce stade
le souhait des pouvoirs publics de de
décaler d'assouplir les cadres les
décisions fondamentales sur la mise en
concurrence pour coter ses acceptions
d'endesa concurrent donc il n'y a pas de
problème de notre côté réseau s'y
préparer réseau doit même veiller à ce
que la concurrence se passe de la
meilleure manière possible aurait sorti
car les connexions sont complètement
pénétré de nos rôles d'équité
concurrentiel face à l'arrivée nouveaux
entrants donc là dessus il n'y a pas de
problème en débit dans cet état d'esprit
les cantons à la partie de la sncf qui
s'affrontent et à la concurrence elle
doit s'y préparer
bien évidemment par exemple l'appel
d'offres lancé par l'état sur les lignes
d'équilibré du territoire il ya un lot
qui va être mise en concurrence sur les
lignes nantes lyon et une en bordeaux
selon est en cours il est à devrait
allouer ce lot
en fin d'année c'était l'horreur dont il
était prévu à ma connaissance le
calendrier n'est pas renier en question
donc à ce stade le calendrier général
d'ouverture à la concurrence dans notre
pays n'est pas remise en question
voilà sur le tgv espagnol que vous
faites sur l'ouverture en espagne
puisque vous avez mentionné ce point ça
me permet de bien qui a réussi la
cohésion est celle dans une décision qui
avait été bien surprise est engagé alors
la crise convient de 19 on verra si sur
la situation espagnole remet en question
la l'ouverture à la concurrence et la
fin d'année 2010 au service d'année 2021
et nous la sncm où nous étions ni en
possibilité de le faire
alors quelle est la raison stratégique
c'est que d'abord nous allons être
attaqué sur le risque français par
plusieurs opérateurs européens dont les
espagnols les espagnols renfe a émis le
souhait de veilhan de concurrencer sur
des lignes qui viendraient de la
frontière de barcelone et plus tôt ou
tard ce côté-là barcelone montpellier
lyon donc les espagnols ont fait part de
leur volonté de venir concurrencer sur
le réseau français y'a pas que ya aussi
les italiens par exemple aussi de très
vite il peut y en avoir d'autres qui se
positionnerait sur le marché de la
grande vitesse français donc première
logique mais si on est attaqué il n'est
pas anormal que nous cherchons à
rattraper en europe les volumes que nous
perdrions il est par le marché que nous
car nous sommes en france
deuxièmement le réseau espagnol s'y
prête parce qu'il est le réseau
ferroviaire espagnol est assez peu
circulé donc quand on il est très
important il n'est plus important en
longueur de kilomètres de voies d'accès
aux français le réseau à grande vitesse
donc il est très important et il ya de
la place voilà c'est comme conduire à
une fée est loin de saturer le réseau de
proposer d'autres offres donc c'est
intéressant pour nous présenter
et troisièmement nous allons tester en
espagne ce que nous avons déployé avec
succès en france et le cosec nico céda
tgv tgv à petit prix et séné 7 ce
principe là que nous souhaitons lancer
en espagne à la fin d'année denis duval
et en fin d'année a raison c'est des
régions que les industriels c'est la
maison france qui se présente parce que
nous allons aller en espagne avec alstom
avec des rebelles ce taux que nous
adapté avec nord espagnole en matière de
fonds de fonctionnement et de
circulation donc ce sont avec des rames
alstom adapté que nous allons en espagne
et donc ça fait quelques temps
d'ailleurs
voilà donc voilà le l'essence de ce
projet espagnol qui illustrent que oui
nous allons rentrer dans l'ère de la
concurrence est selon moi la crise du
virus ne va pas arrêter la tectonique
des plaques et la can que la concurrence
va bien se déployer en france et en
europe avec des premiers effets dès
cette année la fête c'était merci le
farandou je veux donner la parole à
martine sidrac bonjour monter ce que
vous m'entendez c'est bien est-ce que
vous m'entendez merci merci beaucoup
monsieur président le mes chers
collègues bonjour monsieur farandou et
bonjour il ya quelques jours le
président de la république annoncé un
début progressive de déconfinement en
partir du 11 mai j'ai cru comprendre des
tours de vaud de vos réponses déjà fait
que vous avez une préférence peut-être
pour un document qui commencerait en
région ile de france
bien évidemment conscient qu'il ne
s'agira pas de baisser la garde d'un
qu'il faudra être extrêmement rigoureux
que ce soit sur le port des masques le
lavage des mains le respect des
distances pour cela a été rappelé et
tout cela pour nous éviter tous
collectivement une deuxième vague dans
ces conditions monsieur farandou comment
comptez vous organiser et réellement ce
retour de dizaines de milliers de
salariés en ile de france puisque je
rappelle quand même que en temps normal
on parle de 5 millions d'usagers au
quotidien et donc comment comptez vous
alliez véritablement cette surpopulation
éventuelle dans des trains avec tous les
gestes barrière qui vont de toute façon
perdurer et s'imposer à nous pour que
justement nous évitions c'est deuxième
vague et si vous permettez une deuxième
petite question c'est celle qui concerne
les tarifs puisque le mois de mai sera
partiellement amputé il y avait eu des
propositions que vous aviez fait
évidemment pour le mois d'avril
comment entrevoyez vous en faites la
tarification futur au regard de ce
déconfinement progressif qui va arriver
merci beaucoup merci de séracs le
président farandou c'est bon d'être
adroit avec suivi et nageurs ya pas que
l'ile-de-france en france mais ile de
france est une région un peu
particulière qui qui qui est bien qu'ils
taisent bois très important à la fois
par sa population par son impact dans la
vie économique de notre pays
le sujet vous poser le sujet central que
nous avons cette clis et comment
transporter les gens parce qu'il ya
besoin les transporter tout en assurant
leur sécurité et celle de vos salariés
évidemment qu'ils sont en première ligne
sur les trans
il ce sujet pas simple il va dès sur
s'amplifier s'intensifier à partir du 11
mai si comme le dit présents dans le
public nous sommes amenés à avoir
davantage de français qui vont
travailler en nombre significatif et
donc davantage de transports alors
proposé puisque donc à mon avis de
france les français ont vraiment besoin
du train pour aller pour aller
travailler
c'était moins vrai en province mais on
sait cornil de france le train est
notamment pour la grande couronne pour
la grande banlieue est absolument
indispensable à la vie des gens pour
qu'ils aillent travailler et y revenir
le soir
idem d'ailleurs pour les pour les pour
les écoles et des lycéens
si la vie scolaire repart il faudra
transporter les élèves et nous savons
que nous avons de nombreux élèves et
lycéens dans l'eau dans nos trains voilà
donc c'est un vrai sujet qui se pose
alors on y travaille d'arrache-pied les
grands principes les grands principes
son respect des gestes barrières bien
évidemment absolument clé sur la
distanciation
il ya une difficulté jeux les jeux les
jeunes et déjà énoncé dans d'ordre dans
une première réponse
nous pensons qu'ils ne sera pas posée
vieux à un chiffre par exemple pour
maintenir la distanciation un mètre ou
un mètre et demi entre les passagers en
transit ou france en mettant 100 % notre
offre habituelle nous pourrions
transporter que 20% du trafic habituel
voilà donc si on nous impose de mettre m
m et demi entre chaque passager avec
100% des trains on ne transporte que 20%
de ce contrat sera pas d'habitude voilà
ça donne le problème donc ça marche pas
ça marche pas si on dit qu environ 50%
des français estimations ce raid est
confiné on n'y arrive pas voilà faut
être clair bon donc comment on fait pour
lever cette difficulté
je pensais le port du masque il faut
vraiment que le pan dumas soit
obligatoire comprend les transports en
commun ou prendre 30 ans ferroviaire
puisque
il avoue aussi pour le digérer donc ça
ça pas encore été dit par les baumes en
public
la perspective a été tracée par le
président la république pour le moment
j'allais décret d'application du cadre
est la traduction concrète s'est pas
encore mis en place
mais c'est la demande la sncf c'est la
demande que formulent lcf au grand
public
en tout cas c'est selon nous la seule
manière de pouvoir transporter plus
demande en eau train d'être à la hauteur
de la demande qui va s'exprimer
notamment en ile de france
voilà non là il ya un sujet majeur il ya
eu c'est un sujet qui est mis sur la
table avec quand on dire la pologne
n'est sûr ça tire la plogue des masques
comment les gens font pour avoir des
basques etc
c'est en tout cas en matière de
transport collectif c'est la même chose
- ratp d'ailleurs au passage je veux pas
répondre à la place de ma collègue de la
ratp ou de mes collègues au petit lait
des bus de la couronne et je pense qu'on
est tous confrontés aux mêmes sujets
donc pour nous la réponse c'est le port
du masque obligatoire pour utiliser les
transports en commun ferroviaire et été
gêné deuxième mort bien sûr nous y
travaillons dans les gares nous devons
faire deux choses d'abord amplifier le
tout ce qu'ils nettoyaient nettoyage des
traits nettoyage des gares et là-dessus
prison saint michel à paris
nous devons nous faisons aujourd'hui
bien évidemment nous ne devrons encore
plus nettoyer ce qu'il y aura plus de
monde quelque part il logique à nettoyer
davantage puisqu'il ya plus de monde
quitte d'ailleurs à laisser les rames en
gare terminus le temps nécessaire de les
nettoyer et d'ailleurs a pénalisé la
rotation des rames étant glisse il faut
le faire nous le sont les gars c'est
pareil pour beaucoup plus de nettoyage
régulier dans les gares et bien deuxième
dimension une troisième dimension
sociale et match yann nettoyage il ya le
filtrage alors dans les gares de
banlieue c'est pas facile je le
reconnais mais il peut y avoir aussi
notamment dans les grandes gares
parisiennes davantage que le filtrage ne
serait ce que pour vérifier que les gens
aillent des masques par exemple je pense
que le sujet de filtrage d'accès à nos
espaces à la fois les gares et les
trains
voilà se pose aussi voilà et je le redis
moi je veux que le train soit perçue
comme quelque chose de l'écologique et
de sanitaires dont nous devons
absolument amplifier l'effort sanitaires
pour ce que les traits soit bien perçu
comme est un élément sûr de voyages
n'ont peut-être que le bruit dans vanier
pourra compléter ce n'est d'accord
monsieur troisième mais tout
allez-y le président péniche et merci
beaucoup réfléchi vous m'entendez
beaucoup mûri très bien réussi merci
beaucoup monsieur président oui un point
important tels que vient de l'indiquer
le président part en nous aujourd'hui
comme l'indiquait nos plans de transport
sont extrêmement allégées
ce qui nous permet de faire un nettoyage
régulier et est facilement lorsque nous
aurons a besoin d'augmenter notre plan
de transport de façon significative
nous aurons également avoir un nouveau
problème à résoudre
c'est ce nettoyage le nettoyage en
parcours déjà par exemple pour le tgv
mais pour les trains de la vie
quotidienne
il faudra qu'on puisse le faire dans les
gares et ces points là vont sans doute
nous obliger à réduire notre plan de
transport pour que très régulièrement
nous puissions effectivement avoir un
aspect sanitaire pour que l'ensemble de
nos voyageurs puissent être sécurisé de
monter à bord de notre 1 go aujourd'hui
nous avons mis en place une petite tasse
force en mauvais français pour pouvoir
réfléchir à d'autres méthodes de
nettoyage puisque aujourd'hui nous
nettoyons intégralement en particulier
les partis qui se sont touchés par les
voyageurs mais nous sommes en train de
travailler pour que à chaque demi tour
de train pour prendre un exemple très
concret nous puissions nettoyer
l'ensemble de nos trains et ces éléments
là vont avoir un effet qui va obérer et
nous y travaillons et un point important
aujourd'hui pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée que l'indiqué le président
farandou aujourd'hui c'est environ un
peu plus de cent mille voyageurs qui
circulent aujourd'hui dans nos trains en
ile-de-france alors que en règle
générale c'est plutôt trois millions et
demi de personnes
pour compléter la réponse dans ces
raisons pour laquelle nous nous sommes
aussi dans les demandes que nous serons
pouvoirs publics d'aller dans les règles
d'application des principes édités par
la république
nous sommes très favorables au maintien
d'un télétravail suffisant il faut pas
que tous les salariés sortent au même
moment on n'y arrivera pas donc il faut
absolument que dans les camps dans les
règles et en augmentation très forte
apporté au bord du travail notamment en
entreprise
on est la recommandation de conserver
une part significative de télétravail
voilà je pense qu'il faut parce qu'on
pas passer leur extrême à l'autre
trop vite
et ça faisait de manière durable parce
que les sujets évoqués par le président
fans chez vont rester dans la thur et
ans contemple le virus sera pas éradiqué
en ce problème là où il faut être très
clair c'est pas des choses qui vont se
s'évaporer en quelques semaines donc
télétravail peut-être aussi lissage des
heures de pointe
peut-être travailler parce que qu'on
n'est pas tout le monde qui se concentre
le matin entre 7h et 8h et qui donc
peut-être faire en sorte que que qu'on
ait un étalage des heures de pointe de
7h à 9h 9h30 10h pour idem le soir de
15h30 à 18h30 19h crois que là encore
cela arrive à étaler les genres de
pointe ça nous aidera à bien maîtriser
ce sujet de capacité et de règles
barrière à bord des trains voilà autant
de recommandations que nous portons et
que nous allons porter auprès des auprès
des banques bic est d'ailleurs si les
sénateurs
s'ils en sont convaincus s'ils pouvaient
nous aider à les relier ça sera bien
volontiers parce que pour apprendre à
pas se tromper quand elle en avant d'un
rendez vous important avec les français
attendent mais sachez que c'est une
préoccupation importante pour moi et
pour mon équipe vous le sentez auprès du
président ils prennent en famille chez
qui nous a répondu c'est important je
passe maintenant la question projet sur
la tarification
ça aussi ça sujets sur lesquels nous
travaillons bien sûr avec l'autorité en
médiatrice ile-de-france mobilité pour
ce qui concerne l'île de france bon vous
avez bien vu que il devra mobilité prend
en compte dans sa logique tarifaire le
fait que l'offre et est très réduite
donc on est déroulée dans des sujets de
remboursement et de gratuité des
désabonnements pendant pendant la
période mettant en place avec avec la
région entre parenthèses c'est encore
pour l'économie qui ce qui s'aggraverait
cc sont des rentrées économique qui ne
se font pas pour l' équilibre financier
de du service public des transports de
voyageurs en ile de france
donc c'est bien sûr quelque chose qui va
alourdir alourdir le sujet pour
l'autorité organisatrice en le faisons
et nous avançons mois après mois et en
étroite collaboration avec de provoquer
sur ces sujets mais dans un sens évident
que le sens de tenir compte de la
tarification de la réalité de lorsque
l'on propose aux voyageurs
vous évoquiez la possibilité que
les sénateurs appuient vos demandes
auprès des pouvoirs publics je peux
d'ores et déjà vous dire qu'on est tout
à fait en phase avec ce que vous venez
de dire puisque vous indiquez dans la
loi de sap interne à notre commission
j'ai déjà beaucoup de réactions
positives par rapport à la proposition
que vous formulez de rendre obligatoire
le port du masque
non simplement bien sûr dans les
transports gérée par la sncf et je crois
dans tous les transports publics
il ya un point aussi qui est évoqué par
mes collègues et que vous n'avez pas
évoqué ce serait semble-t-il l'utilité
pour pas dire la nécessité d'avoir aussi
des solutions de gel hydroalcoolique
parce que si on a un masque et pour tous
notamment la barre ou tout autre support
dans le train ou dans le métro on sait
très bien que ça peut poser des
difficultés
donc est-ce que vous avez réfléchi aussi
à cette possibilité d'avoir une espèce
de titres avec un gel hydroalcoolique
pour les passagers oui il est heureux il
en est là dessus l'idéal ce serait de
pouvoir du jet la sortie du travail
parce que c'est éventuellement été
confrontés à des parties des parties
métalliques d'entre eux où l assise est
de prendre une barre à 6 à gauche frère
n'est pas fou qui est de saisir une
barre pour ne pas tomber dans le train
donc on est en train de regarder comment
dans les dents les gars on pourrait
mettre à disposition du gel qui
permettraient de sécuriser les voyageurs
en ce en se lavant les mains dans les
sorties du train je vois que le
présentera ni chez souhaite aussi
compléter ma réponse donc s'il est
d'accord
allez-y même si j'ai encore beaucoup de
moments de prise de parole mais ça va
être ça va être très court pour
compléter ce point par rapport aux
trains du quotidien pour les tgv ça nous
en train de regarder comment nous allons
pouvoir équiper nos sanitaires pour
pouvoir distribuer du gel
hydroalcoolique à bord des tgv
merci beaucoup monsieur et président je
vais donner la parole à jean françois
longeot merci monsieur le président j'ai
trop question est une question sur les
tarifs moyens groupe ils sont que les
tarifs moyens comptes
et je voudrais avoir votre sentiment sur
ce sujet serait passé 85 euros en
première personne à strasbourg euros en
2e classe et sur la suppression est
significative de jeu de ligne notamment
sur valence tgv tous les samedis et un
passage obligatoire par paris alors
c'est vrai que s'il ne français pas des
cons finis tout de suite ça va poser un
certain nombre de problèmes
et puis besançon roissy charles de
gaulle et puis une troisième question
sur les travaux lorsqu'on avait
auditionné au titre de la commission du
développement durable
jacques rapoport il nous avait expliqué
qu'un certain nombre de lignes sur
lesquelles les trains roulaient à une
vitesse trop tellement réduite compte
tenu de l'état du réseau
alors ma question ce serait est ce que
vous pensez de la période est propice à
certains travaux notamment sur les voies
qui ne peuvent plus être entretenues est
ce que cette période de confinement où
il ya effectivement beaucoup moins de
circulation de trains pourraient être
prises ce qui éviterait ce effectivement
de travailler la nuit ou de fermer cette
annonce puisque malheureusement compte
tenu du contexte beaucoup moins de
trains de circuler
merci pour vos réponses merci le selon
joe monsieur le président un enfant sans
doute oui oui sa première question je
n'ai pas la réponse à votre question à
votre question donc les frags réponse
peut-être en approche pourrait donc nous
ferait un bon président oui on voit de
réponse par écrit derrière elle on
comprend votre question je ne maîtrise
pas que la qualification de tout est dit
je vous prie de m'en excuser
en tout cas sur le en termes de
principes il n'y a pas de volonté
d'augmenter les prix certainement pas il
se peut certainement raison donc il ya
pu avoir quelques erreurs dans la
tarification
on prend le poids et on le regarde
sauf si présent felishea la réponse moi
je les parts non il n'a pas non plus
donc on prend le point et on vous répond
sur les ajustements des desserts que oui
on en est bien conscient sénateurs on a
été amené à réduire considérablement
leurs tentes a forcément des des lignes
qui ne sont beaucoup moins et les arts
vivants même qu'ils ne sont plus assurés
des relations qui ne sont plus assurés
ça fait vraiment partie de l'effort les
fonds de la sncf à la décision de
grandes villes mais il faut et dans les
7 % tgv qui roulent en a comme % de
trafic et ceux qui tout à fait normal
puisque tu dire les gens sont censés
rester chez eux
on a vu d'ailleurs et c'est pas un
regret mais enfin on a vu ce qui s'était
passé alors que le confinement n'avait
pas été encore annoncée par près de la
république
le fameux week end avant d une espèce
d'exode de parisiens qui sont tous
partis dominants secondaire on voit très
bien que s'il ya trop de trains il peut
y avoir un usage abusif des trains qui
circulent
voilà donc je pense que lorsqu'il me
concerne je n'ai pas de regrets même si
je suis conscient que ça peut gêner les
usagers ou des clients je n'ai aucun
regret à avoir
affalés la voilure de manière très
importante tout en maintenant un minimum
un minimum vital pour les poulets pour
des relations nationales
on n'est pas le choix point de la
situation sanitaire du pays d'imposer m
je suis conscient qu'il peut y avoir des
effets des effets indésirables par
rapport à telle ou telle besoin de 2,2
déplaceront sur sur les relations fait
sur l'île de france
bon voilà c'est la question
effectivement de confinement régionales
on verra bien on verra bien si le le
gouvernement décidé de confiner
l'ile-de-france plus longtemps et ouvrir
dans notre région mais on s'adaptera
c'est pas ce qu'on s'est pas dit ce
qu'on recommande nous mais nous on est
votre avis parce que c'est là de
préserver la santé des français et dont
bien évidemment donc 6 à l'option qui
retenus par les pouvoirs publics on
verra il peut y avoir la place dans ce
cas là ça fait l'ajustement de relations
tgv est train régional pour les très
grandes régions où walter régional sur
deux régions limitrophes
si ces deux régions et elle est confinée
bon voilà ce sont des scénarios qu'on
apporte pour travailler on travaillera
si besoin en est
en fonction des décisions prises par les
pouvoirs publics sur la manière de des
consignes et de manière régionale
voilà donc à suivre sur les travaux à
auxerre vous avez raison quand bien même
on pourrait faire davantage de travaux
mais le problème c'est que les règles de
confinement s'applique aussi aux
entreprises de travaux voilà donc donc
malheureusement c'est pas simple non
plus d'engager des travaux je n'évoquais
dans une des réponses précédentes on a
connu un arrêt d'une entreprise de btp
et puis quand c'est exactement il ya
quelques semaines et l'entreprise de btp
les belles et grosses entreprises
allegro nageurs français ont arrêté les
travaux pour des problèmes sanitaires
parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à subtiliser
leurs salariés d'ailleurs d'accéder
danser dans ses salariés il ya là il ya
là il ya une part non négligeable qui
sont pas français qui sont repartis dans
leur pays d'origine ils ça va prendre du
temps à les faire revenir d'autant plus
que se déplacer en europe n'est pas
simple non plus donc voilà donc on est
certain on a la place pour faire des
travaux mais on n'a plus les entreprises
pour le faire j'allais dire donc on n'a
pas donc plus à à croire d'appât bureau
on n'a pas pu accroître notre capacité à
faire des travaux
on en fait quelques heures et on n'a pas
arrêté de faire des travaux mais on le
fait de manière ajusté et ses travaux il
faut les faire bien sûr on est tous
d'accord faut les faire pour que le
réseau fonctionne voilà donc on va faire
des travaux
on aura un peu de place aussi parce
qu'on a vu que le plan transport sera
pas repris à 100% tout de suite donc on
aura peut-être moins de mai - je mets
mes juin des trous on aura des trains
n'est pas à 100% et donc le phénomène
que vous indiquez sera encore ouais on a
une capacité en matière de crayon
créneau hier pour faire des travaux de
cours plus que les travaux de nomi donc
ça c'est intéressant mais on a de voir
une nouvelle planification affaire qui
tiennent compte des trains qui roulent
qui tiennent compte de la capacité des
entreprises à s'engager pour faire des
travaux
c'est un travail que sur le plot
travaillant et je vous le redis on le
travaille avec les régions parce que les
régions elles mêmes peuvent vous
souhaitez prioriser certains travaux par
rapport à d'autres et il faut aussi
connaître sur les conséquences des
travaux sur les pentes transports
ce travail d'ajustement des travaux
étaient en cours de construction il sera
largement partagée avec les régions donc
y compris les régions du sud que vous
semblez représentés
merci je crois beaucoup au groupe un peu
les questions qui nous restent parce
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de questions et
un temps limité donc j'ai donné ma
parole à monsieur gontard et ensuite je
donnerai ma bulle monsieur bah oui merci
monsieur
non monsieur le président farandou
voyagea beaucoup de vous apporter déjà
beaucoup de réponses notamment sur sur
le lien avec les régions et les
autorités organisatrices peut-être juste
une précision puisqu'il ya des autorités
oui notre sous-région qui ont mis en
place la gratuité pour les personnels
soignants notamment qu'elle du coup
liens et comment vous positionner par
rapport à ça et puis également sur le
protocole sanitaire sur dans les trains
que ce soit eux masque chez hydro
alcooliques des infections dont j'ai
bien entendu mais je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'il ya un protocole claire et
puis une bonne communication parce que
c'est vrai que sinon il faut rassurer je
dirais les usagers sinon ils vont se
tourner vers la voiture individuelle
vulgairement dommageable et puis j'ai
particulièrement apprécié mon vote
description et vos discours sur le fret
ainsi que vous avez parlé d'intérêt
général art et environnemental est
d'aider le fret avec de l'argent public
vous avez même décrit un véritable
service public d'intérêt stratégique
donc la nécessité d'avoir un vrai
contrôle public est-ce que derrière ça
c'est pour vous une remise en cause de
la privatisation de fret sncf et qu'
est-ce que c'est du coup une sortie du
dogme de la concurrence
alors vous l'avez pas dit comme ça mais
j'en entends camp quand vous avez parlé
de l'ouverture à la concurrence j'ai
plutôt entendu du tout une fatalité que
vraiment quelque chose de positif
donc quand vous expliquer là dessus et
puis moi sur la question du plan
marshall très bien mais je me demande
s'il n'y a pas de nécessité
justement pour le jour d'après d'ouvrir
des états généraux du fret ferroviaire
et de mettre les différents acteurs
autour de la table
voilà merci beaucoup merci
bon car l'un julien germano julien oui
oui ici sinon oui non ou bien si bonjour
monsieur le président farandou ouais
j'avais une petite question qui est a
encore eu pour le jour après jour
d'après parce que c'est vrai que là et
vous êtes mobilisés on peut que
féliciter l'ensemble de vos services sur
cette mobilisation sur cette situation
tout à fait particulier il va bien
falloir aussi se projeter dans l'avenir
vous savez comme on dit à lyon est mon
avenir donc si on aime l'avenir se dire
comment est ce que le travail est
poursuivie actuellement je travaille sur
les petites lignes vous savez que quand
on a été arrêté par les grecs d'une part
le d'autres pas on avait au début
d'ailleurs et se dire comment on
continue à travailler comme en service
continuer à travailler sur les petites
lignes et savoir comment on va pouvoir
persuader les gens de reprendre les
transports publics puisque actuellement
on nous dit compte tenu de cette
pandémie quand vous circulez éviter de
prendre les transports publics
les collègues ont bien évoqué tout ce
qui va pouvoir être mis en place et vous
y avez répondu en partie sur ce qu'on
peut mettre en place pour éviter ensuite
que la pandémie se propage par les
transports publics justement mais moi ma
question c'est est-ce que quelqu'un est
en train de travailler sur le trail bro
gen sur les trains légers sur la suite
comment on va pouvoir continuer à
irriguer territoire pour vraiment là
répondre au développement durable
merci monsieur lang monsieur monsieur
gold et ensuite que vous pouvez répondre
à ces trois questions monsieur de 3,5
monsieur gold oui oui monsieur le
président à lézignan allez merci
président remercie monsieur le président
à hambourg mon intervention mois vise à
apporter des précisions sur des
questions déjà été posée beaucoup
prônent
pour que cette crise exceptionnelle sur
l'occasion à ces environnements une
accélération de la transition écologique
ne pas sacrifier le climat sur l'autel
de la relance
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
chargé trouver des solutions au
réchauffement climatique a transmis
récemment 50 propositions gouvernement
parmi lesquels un vote fort au train
parmi les freins de nos concitoyens nous
hp régulier de transport ferroviaire les
tarifs qui revient juger des poids trop
élevé et figure en bonne place
moi j'aimerais connaître les intentions
de la sncf donc en plus accessible et
plus attractif le train pour les usagers
pas seulement de france et dans un
contexte de pertes financières liées
notamment à la crise
et puis deuxième question des travaux de
rénovation et de modernisation des voies
étaient planifiés sur certaines lignes
qui accuse un retard important je pense
notamment aux trains d'équilibré du
territoire les plus particulièrement à
celui la ligne d'arrivée rebonds et là
j'aimerais savoir quels seront les
conséquences de la crise en termes de
calendrier et de priorisation des
travaux pour être plus clair
y at-il aujourd'hui une remise en cause
potentielle sur ses lignes d'équilibré
territoire je vous remercie
merci monsieur présent farandou donc je
vous propose de répondre aux questions
de monsieur gontard mobilier à monsieur
gold première oui il ya un sujet central
qui est repris par rapport à par
plusieurs sénateurs il faut dire qu'il
nous préoccupe a nous aussi assez de
démontrer le caractère sadique arbitres
je pense que c'est évident on voit ce
qui se passe dans d'autres pays
pour la chine mais on sait qu'en chine
les gens se sont précipités dans les
voitures et nyon et ont abandonné les on
va donner en tout cas sont beaucoup
moins présents dans les transports
collectifs
c'est l'enjeu stratégique majeur si à la
sortie de crise le grand gagnant de la
crise c'est la voiture et humide elle je
pense que on aura doublé quelque chose
est en tout cas on peut pas être
satisfait si on est en plus je suis en
train de parler à la commission
d'aménagement
on peut pas être satisfait de cette
sortie la dont le jaillir le fardeau de
la preuve il est chez nous avons là bien
compris c'est à nous de démontrer par
des processus nouveaux appareils par des
choses nouvelles fortes qu'eux
prendre le train n'est pas un george
hill pour sa santé personnelle c'est
très très important qu'on fasse beaucoup
de choses en matière de nettoyage en
matière de protection en matière de gcc
centrale et c'est fondamental et je peux
vous dire qu'on va mettre le paquet là
dessus parce que c'est vital pour nous
quelque part on veut conserver une
utilité forte dans le pays
il faut absolument qu'on soit au rendez
vous de ce challenge de la situation
sanitaire donc c'est un seul enjeu
majeur et vous êtes plusieurs à l'avoir
souligné sur sur le fret peut-être je je
je donnerai la parole à fric et du plan
marshall fret
je vais répondre à la concurrence c'est
la concurrence moi je suis très
factuelle en tant que présidents
d'entreprises publiques
je suis citoyen comme les autres mais
mais je suis là pour appliquer des
règles que la république se donne donc
la république a souhaité que la
concurrence arriver à notre pays d'être
eh bien voilà contact appareils en
service et que ça vient du traité de
rome
quand même le traité c'est pas nouveau
voilà c'est donc pas être surpris
on sait très bien que dans l'est que ce
principe d'une concurrence que dès lors
qu'elle est régulé dès lors qu'on fait
attention aux enjeux sociaux qui vont
avec et qu'elle se traduit pas par un
petit social il n'est pas du tout ben
voilà qu'elle n'est pas aussi se fait
pas au détriment du bien-être social des
salariés
on sait que c'est un fondement important
de la construction européenne dont il
n'y a pas de surprise c'est un
calendrier qui s'est déroulée
j'y reviens pas mais voilà le temps est
venu maintenant de l'appliquer notre
pays
dès lors les enjeux pour la sncf il y en
a deux le premier c'est que les
activités de monopole de l'accès de ses
activités de gestionnaire de réseau et
le gestionnaire des gars se fasse en
parfaite équité par rapport à la
concurrence donc ça c'est très très
important et je suis responsable devant
le devant l'état il est devant la rt et
devant le parlement de la bonne
application de ce principe et j'y
veillerai scrupuleusement
donc voilà donc ça c'est le premier
élément est le deuxième élément c'est
que dans la partie
des opérateurs de la sncf il faut qu'ils
se battent sur le rapport qualité prix
comme toute entreprise qui est soumise à
la concurrence et bien c'est le
consommateur qui décide c'est le client
qui décide et le client qui soit
voyageurs pour le tgv qui soit charger
pour le fret
donc ils soient autorités organisatrices
pour les transports il choisira le
meilleur rapport qualité-prix donc à
nous d'améliorer notre qualité
à nous de tenir nos coûts et de tenir
nos prix voilà donc c'est la règle du
jeu nous l'acceptons voilà donc on va on
va la mettre en oeuvre sans sans état
d'âme qualifiant par ailleurs la
concurrence c'est à la fois souple et
les chercheurs à sotchi quand vous la
recevez pour la première fois moi j'ai
la chance de la connaître
puisque vous le savez il certains
d'entre vous le savent j'ai été
président de keolis pendant sept ans
laconi la concurrence était tous les
jours donc voilà je sais ce que c'est il
ya des bonbons et les jours on gagne à
la démo mais les jours en faire et quand
on perd faut se demander pourquoi on a
perdu pour s'améliorer et espérer gagner
la prochaine fois que le contrat
reviendrait sur le marché voilà donc
c'est qu'il n'est pas les seuls la
plupart des entreprises d'autres pays
sont soumis à la concurrence concurrence
française concurrence internationale
c'est le lot finalement des entreprises
à de souliers à concurrence pour la sncf
ça sera un choc parce que c'est la
première fois et quand c'est la première
fois forcément votre courbe
d'apprentissage elle est juste au début
vous n'avez pas encore appris à faire
face à la concurrence donc je dis pas
que c'est celle je dis pas que c'est
facile je ne dis pas que ces données est
évident voilà que je dis les choses
bon ça c'est le côté le choc après le
côté opportunités c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire de se remettre en
question de se remettre en cause d'être
innovant de d'être clair sur nos points
forts parce que nous avons des points
forts a la sncf on les démontre
d'ailleurs dans la cette crise a je
crois que c'est aussi le formidable
occasion de démontrer les points forts
de sncf
ils sont nombreux voilà à nous de savoir
les jouets à ne savoir faire fructifier
à régler même et de et d'avancé devant
la concurrence sur sur la question posée
par van hamme julien sur le jour d'après
eux vont d'après ou sur la presse vous
avez entièrement raison
et sachez qu'une partie de mon temps de
mon de montant de mon cerveau et de moi
et de mes équipes c'est justement de
regarder loin de regarder à long terme
et moi je suis convaincu que quoi qu'il
se passe
le ferroviaire et la solution est la
solution en matière de mobilité
il ya pas plus écologique que le
ferroviaire et pour longtemps et c'est
pas demain qu'on aura des camions
électriques même le déploiement des
voitures électriques il est tous les
petits il ya la flotte électrique elle
est tout petit temps et pour longtemps
quand on regarde les chiffres donc à
l'évidence le train pour lui beaucoup
moins que la voiture la voiture
voilà le très beau coup beaucoup moins
que les camions beaucoup mais que
l'avion l'avion pour lui beaucoup
avaient le kérosène donc à mon avis pour
les vols domestiques sagan bien mieux
prendre le train que de prendre l'avion
non oui pour moi le ferroviaire et la
solution y compris dans les dents et
eric en maintenance
alors c'était pas le train d'aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on a un vrai sujet de
réinvention du ferroviaire dans les
territoires moins denses parce que le
ferroviaire de gourdes 8 et trop coûteux
coûte trop cher quand on veut le
déployer dans les territoires donc il
faut le réinventer
il faudra réinventer à la fois le
matériel roulant et là vous avez raison
madame du lien il faut y croire et mon
contrat à hydrogène léger léger parce
que mon écoute je sais qu'il faut vue il
faut vraiment inventé des mode
ferroviaire adaptés à ces dessertes l'a
peut-être aussi admettre qu'ils seront
cédés certes la suède multimodal vous
être aussi accepter la combinaison des
solutions routières comme le cas c'est
d'être mix de trains et de cars et
peut-être d'autres formes de déplacement
on parle beaucoup de talent est autonome
aussi etc je pense que l'innovation doit
être très forte et très puissante pour
apporter des solutions de transport
collectif dans les territoires en
matière d'énergie les trains hydrogène
sont certainement pour moi et sur le
chemin d'avenir
sachez que la direction de la recherche
et l'innovation qui est très en pointe
sur ce sujet reisser nous devons être
capables d'avoir des prototypes le train
hydrogène de traire hybride allie remix
diesel électrique
on est capable d'ailleurs de reprendre
les flottes ancien des flottes pied
c'est l'ancien les âges ici ce qu'on
appelle les agc autorails de grande
capacité et de les transformer en train
hybride donc avec une partie électrique
voilà donc tout ça on est vraiment à la
valeur et je suis convaincu vous avez
raison valable à triste qu'il faut se
projeter au-delà il faut pas avoir le
nez dans le guidon la crise immédiate il
faut bien sûr réfléchiront jour qui
vient on semaines qui viennent ne vaut
aussi se projeter sur les années qui
viennent
voilà sur les tarifs elle a peut-être
ces jeux peut recéler la parole le
premier temps présidente annie sié et
ensuite auprès de leurs de l'ordre
prendra le succès frais oui vous avez
raison le train doit être accessible à
la fois un accès physique aussi un accès
d'accès tarifaire c'est vraiment ce que
la sncf ait a fait ces dernières années
l'exemple le plus spectaculaire sont des
bourricots avec un accès populaire à la
grande vitesse
mais je veux bien passer la parole pris
en famille chez qui pourra développer sa
philosophie tarifaire au moment où il
prend la présidence de la savoie yaggeur
donc s'il est d'accord plusieurs bourgs
et on donne la présidence l'avait
contacté leur fille a fait brièvement ce
que j'ai encore cinq demandes de prise
de parole mais je donne bien volontiers
la parole reese hoffa nicher merci
beaucoup monsieur président oui pour
faire très bref comme l'indiqué le
président farandou sur les trains je
parle uniquement d'être un long parcours
de trains à grande vitesse
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable succès
que le succès willow que nous avons
lancé depuis plusieurs années et
aujourd'hui nous avons rencontré un
marché puisque ça fait partie des trains
qui sont les mieux remplis de ceux de
l'entreprise et nous avons décidé de
poursuivre le développement de meego
pour pouvoir donner aux français
l'accès à la grande vitesse à petit
et d'ailleurs si je me permets de
revenir sur ce sujet c'est ce que nous
demande aujourd'hui l'espagne en
proposant ses trains de grande vitesse à
bas prix de toute façon à permettre à
leurs concitoyens également de faire
cesser train de longs parcours juste un
tout petit point sur l'augmentation des
tarifs les tarifs du ferroviaire n'ont
pas augmenté depuis plusieurs années
nous avons renoncé depuis plusieurs
années à l'augmentation tarifaire que
nous faisions tous les ans au 1er
janvier
nous n'avons pas fait cette année mais
ça fait déjà au moins trois ans que
c'était augmentation tarifaire n'a pas
été fait et lorsque je regarde les
courbes sur les tarifs moyens que nous
appliquons ces tarifs baissent d'année
en année grâce au fait que nous
proposons des petits prix et grâce au
fait du développement des trains we go
sur l'ensemble de notre territoire
merci vous souhaitiez que je préside aux
normes complète
peut-être le meilleur de nous mêmes une
complaisance ou les six partage de
volumes en remercie ce président donc
pour compléter les propos de président
farandou
je pense que derrière une notion de
frais de service public je préfère une
notion de fret d'intérêt général car la
concurrence est un fait l'existant
matière à tramo dalle ne faut pas
oublier la concurrence de la route et je
voudrais souligner que dans l'activité
de fret sncf aujourd'hui à peu près 50%
de son activité est quasiment de fait et
c'est la régulation de la concurrence
naturelle qui s'est faite est avec la
route
c'est à dire que des concurrents sur le
rail qui sont là depuis 15 ans ne sont
pas venus attaquer une partie de notre
trafic marginalement ils le feront
marginalement parce que la concurrence
c'est la route et là on est vraiment sur
des questions de politique publique
j'aurais peut-être juste insister sur le
fait de pourquoi ça peut réussir le
transfert modal dans les années qui
viennent
d'abord parce que je pense la crise
sanitaire actuelle dans l'esprit des
français va rejoindre la crise
climatique
moins de pollution moins de camions sur
les routes une logistique terrestre
recentraliser en europe et plus
respectueuses du développement durable
c'est sans doute une attente très forte
et je crois qu'on a une opportunité
historique de concilier l'économie et
l'écologie intra avec une locomotive un
wagon ce n'est pas écologique mais dire
que le tra ça coûte cher et que donc
c'est pas économique
c'est faux également puisque ça génère
des économies d'externalités tout à fait
significatives et c'est à partir de là
qu'on peut définir des politiques
publiques de réinvestissement en matière
du fret ferroviaire
donc moi j'achète les deux idées
personnellement à la fois celle du plan
marshall sous l'angle de
l'investissement de modernisation que ce
soit des trains de fret ou de
l'infrastructure mais j'achète aussi les
ethnies généraux du fret ferroviaire ce
parce que il faut se dire que notre
industrie française est extrêmement
diffuse sur le territoire on a plus de
1000 usine embranchée y compris dans des
territoires diffus qui expédie des tout
petits lots vers une vingtaine de
destinations
il conte besoin a quand même d'accéder à
harare d'autrans européen puisque
l'industrie est essentiellement
européenne donc se réapproprier cette
territoire industriel accompagner ce
mouvement je pense que les états
généraux qui associerait l'état les
régions des chargeurs mais aussi des
citoyens pourraient avoir à vrai intérêt
pour retrouver de nouvelles solutions
innovantes
merci beaucoup je vais donner la parole
à présent à madame préville monsieur
jacques reçu également après lil wayne
préville que vous nous entendez à la
prairie monsieur jacques rey a peut-être
vous m'entendez président en moré merci
pour cette belle audition je voulais
saluer les cheminots saluer monsieur
delorme monsieur famille choe monsieur
farandou j'ai vraiment confiance sur
l'aspect sécurité sanitaire mais je veux
dire sur une autre question monsieur le
président farandou lorsque vous êtes
venu au sénat pour votre audition
initial je vous avais interrogé sur
votre habileté à savoir si le pdg de la
sncf de ne pas être quelqu'un d'
extrêmement habile pour circuler entre
les injonctions paradoxales du
gouvernement moins d'argent plus de
service de la paix sociale alors ma
question sur l'habileté je vous l'a
reposé aujourd'hui président farandou
est ce que dans cette crise il ne s'agit
pas enfin d'aller trouver la ressource
financière permanente pour enfin prendre
en compte les externalités positives qui
ont été largement évoqués par nos
collègues
après le nouveau pacte ferroviaire et la
lhomme il n'y a pas de responsable à
question du transport et du carbone et à
une malédiction française de l'écotaxe
donc est-ce que l'habileté aujourd'hui
pour les voyageurs pour le fret
ce n'est pas d'aller chercher cette
ressource et éventuellement ne faut-il
pas y aller
au niveau européen au travers des
paquets mobilité voir au travers du
green new deal européen je le dis ainsi
président farandou parce que lors de
l'audition du ministre la semaine
dernière je lui ai demandé s'il serait
aussi l'est pour sauver le ferroviaire
que l'aérien et savez le
l'impression dans la visioconférence que
ses yeux briller pour au nom de ben
smith alors vous saurez être habile à ce
point est retourné la tête 0/3 dans la
crise
je pense que vous êtes avis les jeux
terminés avec la question puisque vous
avez réussi incroyablement attachant la
main sur sncf réseau et jeu je regrette
qu'on n'ait pas pu lui auditionné lors
de son recrutement monsieur l'allemand
qui a l'air d'être au demeurant très
efficace et les sympathiques
je souhaiterais que notre commission
puisse l'auditionner car le fameux coup
contre performance de 7,7 réseau qui est
déterminant pour le prix des sillons et
qui est prévu dans la loi est en retard
et il va être déterminant pour le fret
pour les petites lignes et sur toute
l'équation ferroviaire tous en dépit des
engagements qui avaient été données aux
parlements je rajoute une dernière
question j'ai fini là pourquoi ne
centralise et pourquoi ne par capelli
requis recapitaliser fret sncf
merci madame président lequel la wii est
ce que vous m'entendez très bien on vous
donne tout de suite
merci merci monsieur le président merci
messieurs les présidents mes chers
collègues
alors d'abord je voulais s'agissant du
déconfinement revenir aux gestes
barrières pensez vous à l'installation
dans les gares ou bien dans les trains
de distributeurs de gel
d'autre part vous avez évoqué la
nécessité et là je pense que nous sommes
plus d'accord que tous les voyageurs et
des masques est ce que vous pensez
également la distribution comme je pense
assez vu dans d'autres pays de masques
sur les quais avant de monter dans les
trains ça aura peut-être un coup mais
voilà ce que vous l'envisagez ensuite ma
question sont sur le fret
alors vous avez évoqué le fait que vous
aviez agi avec les céréales
est-ce que c'était des clients habituels
ou bien est ce que ce sont de nouveaux
clients qui se sont manifestés et dans
quelle mesure vous envisagé puisque on
est tous d'accord que le fret a quelque
chose de fret ferroviaire est vertueux
bien évidemment je pense qu'on est
nombreux à être d'accord sur le sujet
est ce que vous envisagez puisque vous
aviez dit vous avez dit tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait inciter les entreprises à
éventuellement envisager cette solution
du fret ferroviaire
est-ce que vous avez déjà des pistes sur
les entreprises qui vous aurait contacté
et alors moi je vous parle d'un
territoire qui est sûr ce qui a été
évoqué tout à l'heure un territoire
d'industrie qui est en 2d dans un
territoire rural un petit peu loin de
tout avec une grosse industrie
agroalimentaire et donc est ce que vous
envisagez comment est ce que vous voyez
le devenir et le la presse finalement
pour développer beaucoup ce fret
ferroviaire et comme vous avez envisagé
également vous aviez évoqué tout à leur
pardon des difficultés sur le fret
ferroviaire
est ce que il s'agirait d'une
recapitalisation et sur les aides que
vous avez envisagé également s comment
vous allez vous vous inscrire si il y
avait dans la presse un grand plan de
relance national
est ce que vous allez le mettre en avant
cette cette problématique du fret et
dans le la relance qui se fera au niveau
européen
est ce que vous allez vous inscrire dans
le new green deal
voilà pour mes questions je remercie
merci monsieur au yacht
parce que monsieur gâtés la wii vous
m'entendez allez-y monsieur parfait
merci pour cette audition de qualité
monsieur le président je voudrais avant
tout remercier la sncf l'ensemble des
équipes pour sa mobilisation son
application et sa réactivité
c'est souvent en face d'ailleurs à
l'adversité qu'on se révèle la sncf est
un groupe qui est à la fois présent à
l'international mais qui se déploie
aussi à travers de multiples filiales
j'ai trois questions qui sait qu'ils
sont liés la première est ce que cette
crise va modifier votre stratégie à
l'international
vous avez déjà sur l'espagne mais est-ce
que ça va modifier globalement votre
stratégie
et est-ce que vous avez des inquiétudes
ou des vigilance particulière sur
certaines de vos filiales
je pense notamment à eurostar je pense
peut-être aussi à keolis tu que vous
connaissez très bien geodis aussi à
travers sa filiale américaine motion et
enfin est-ce que vous envisageriez à
terme de la cession d'actifs pour
reconstituer entre guillemets du capital
merci je vais donner peut-être la parole
aux deux derniers sénateurs qui l'ont
demandé comme son oreille réponse de
paix
madame ramon oui bonjour ma présidence
je voulais poser une question sur les
travaux de les travaux et en particulier
sur la reprogrammation des travaux de
développement mais je pars nolan qui
peut évoquer mais nous n'avons pas dit
grand chose
voilà c'est tout je m'arrêterai là bien
et pour terminer je donne ma parole
oui mais bonjour président vous
m'entendez eh bien bon merci merci
messieurs pour toutes ces explications
aussi je me joins aux remerciements
exprimés par le collègue pour l'ensemble
du travail qui a été fait par la sncf
pour assurer un service de qualité
alors moi je voudrais poser deux
questions sur les sujets antérieures à
la crise mais qui se pencheront revenir
dans l'actualité qui concerne les
questions sociales concernant les
négociations futures du cadre social
concernant la branche heroes bière et
spécifiques dans le cadre contractuel
comment envisagez vous donc de deux
d'aborder ces négociations et j'ai aussi
question que concernant ces négociations
donc après leur échec
la loi permet à l'état de légiférer par
ordonnance donc quelle est votre
position sur ce point
et puis une inquiétude de deux là de
l'usagé de la ligne paris de la dre que
mes collègues ont bien comprendre pour
ce qui
n'utilise vous avez parlé de grands
projets qui vont être devoir programmer
et retardé qu'en sera-t-il de la ligne
lnpn je vous remercie
merci beaucoup à tocqueville ce
président farandou mais s'appelait
président je vous laisse la parole pour
répondre à cette dernière série de
questions très bien donc il ya pas mal
de sujets qui se recoupent donc cela
permettra également d'apporter une
réponse groupe et aux questions posées
par les sénatrices et les sénateurs donc
sur sur la partie car clarification du
duo du besoin d'argent public
c'est une vraie bonne question c'est une
question centrale pour le ferroviaire à
le ferroviaire la caractéristique de
consommer beaucoup d'argent en matière
de capitaux c'est un réseau ferroviaire
sans réseau ferroviaire du pays qui
appartient à la nation il faut le
maintenir il faut le développer
on connaît tous le problème que nous
avons relevé ces cas pas dans des
décennies le réseau ferroviaire
classique n'a pas n'a pas reçu les la
quantité de maintenant suffisante et
donc il est dégradé
il habille il est dégradé l'âge moyen du
réseau classique et très bas il est
autour de 35 ans quand le réseau
ferroviaire allemand de 17 ans voilà
donc on sait pourquoi on sait pas ce que
l'effort a été surtout porté sur le tgv
est bon c'est comme ça
c'est d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs ça
aussi qui a provoqué la dette la dette
globale du système
voilà on connaît l'histoire bon
maintenant donc côté réseau c'est tout à
fait clair
l'ambition de rénovation du réseau
passera par la quantité d'argent qu'on
peut y apporter
voilà c'est tout à fait clair ce qu'il
faut aussi en les idées claires c'est
qu'il ya deux notions qui sont atteintes
est menée et de demande de l'argent il
ya ce qu'on appelle dans votre
vocabulaire la régénération
si en gros le remplacement des rails
vieux pardon donc le l'horizon il est le
maire après si c'est qu'il est neuf donc
du temps moyen en panne et on n'a pas
moderniser on n'a pas n'a pas changé sa
façon en équipements technologiques
on ajuste les composants qui était lieu
on les remplace par des copeaux temps 9
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
régénération quand on parle d'âge moyen
on parle de ça c'est ça quand on parle
de remplacement des rails remplacement
des caténaires remplacement des postes
d'aiguillage remplacement le
remplacement des de l'alimentation
électrique ca c
les composantes du réseau là-dessus
fondé pour donner de l'argent il ya
deuxième niveau et c'est là d'ailleurs
qu'on retrouve la problématique des du
réseau structurant des petites lignes
voilà quel est le périmètre de l'effort
de régénération est ce que c'est tout le
réseau y compris les petites lignes ou
est ce que c'est que le réseau principal
qui est porté par les eaux et les
pipelines dans ce cas là qu'est ce qu'on
fait
est ce que sont les régions qui doit les
prendre en charge de ces taxes le
deuxième sujet quand on parle moins dans
le pays mais qui est aussi important et
là dessus je peux vous dire connaître
par avance par rapport aux pays
européens
c'est ce qu'on appelle la modernisation
de réseaux la monnaie sein du réseau
vous avez deux grands le grand dossier
vous avez dossier de la signalisation
européenne ce qu'on appelle le rtms et
d'une nouvelle signalisation
intéropérables qui parle qui permet de
passer d'un pays à l'autre qui permet
aussi d'avoir plus de capacités sur les
lignes et là dessus on est très en
retard par rapport aux autres pays
européens
et là encore il faut de l'argent pour
équiper le réseau français de rtl est-ce
que vous avez une autre forme de
généralisation
c'est ce qu'on appelle les sens mais
comment centralisée du réseau sert d
immenses possible il ya un grand rayon
d'action qui permet d'être plus
efficaces au plan au plan financier
parce que vous avez vous avez beaucoup
de silence
nous nous enlever beaucoup de petits
postes perdus dans la nature avec avec
des aiguilles en peu partout où les
concentrés lors des grands postes ou
gagner en économie vous gagnez aussi en
efficacité vous gagner en fiabilité
voilà donc donc les besoins sont énormes
et franchement c'est un vrai sujet alors
pour le goût de politique générale c'est
quelle est la quantité d'argent que le
pays veut mettre par rapport à quel
projet cap qu'elle qu'elle provient de
réseau ferroviaire
ça c'est c'est un projet qui qui qui qui
est sur la table depuis longtemps voilà
et c'est là le sénateur jacques un as
raison c'est vraiment une question
d'argent
voilà si on met en fonction de l'argent
que le pays va mettre en oeuvre un
résultat plus ou moins différents ça
c'est le premier sujet c'est juillet
d'investissement pour le goût sur le
sujet du fret
il ya deux sujets bien sujet
d'investissements là aussi il ya des
investissements à faire si on veut que
que sur le réseau qui compense le réseau
sur nos côtes mais pas que ça peut être
aussi sur les locomotives etc
et puis un sujet dead parce que je pense
que malgré ça la concurrence nokia est
tellement puissant qu'il faut aider en
fonctionnement lusage les ddd fret
donc il ya deux grands de grandes de
grands vecteurs c'est ce transport
son label l'aide à la presse chaque fois
qu'on transporte containers de bateaux
sur un train il ya une baisse qui
attrape le container donc au moyen d'une
subvention autorisée par bruxelles en
mai sur des choses autorisée par
bruxelles des aides à la presse que
certains pays utilisent beaucoup et puis
elle est aussi l'un d'entre eux wagon
isolé pour avoir une la desserte diffuse
qui évoquait le président de l'ordre
d'un tout le territoire dans ses bilans
branchement au réseau dont les
entreprises ont besoin
il faut aider l'usager du wagon isolé
voilà donc ce assez c'est ça le
dispositif
et c'est vrai que ce dispositif c'est
une question d'argent ou est clair donc
on ça renvoie au plan marshall
ça renvoie au plan de relance bien
évidemment dans le plan de relance que
le pays est en train de préparer après
cette crise j'espère je souhaite qu'ils
aient une dimension fret important une
dimension fret et une dimension réseau
voilà c'est vrai que ce plan marshall ce
plan de relance est peut-être l'occasion
wild l'occasion combiné avec vous avez
qui sur les édiles parce que s'il ya des
l'impulsion européenne pour mieux
équiper le réseau ferroviaire français
et soutenir le développement du credoc
pays là une opportunité il ya une
fenêtre de tir
j'espère que nous seront utilisés en
nous regroupant par rapport à ses
objectifs
ça c'est un lien moment comme qu'il faut
voir à nouveau sur la question position
le sur le déconfinement et les gestes
barrière distribution de jeunes oui on a
dit oui dans les gares et dans les
trains quand on le peut en plus elle est
élevée que dans les trains de la vie
quotidienne
mais oui faut du gel distribution de
masques on verra ça avec des pouvoirs
publics attention la sncf va prendre sur
ses épaules la distribution de masques à
toute la population française ça c'est
pas possible
voilà donc on est prêt à contribuer et
on est prêt à aider mais encore en plus
engagement je pense que équiper les
français de masquer sa relève largement
des pouvoirs publics
voilà donc à nous d articuler avec eux
pour autant je redis que je souhaite que
pour prendre le train on est en mars que
ça je pense qu'il va falloir le dire et
le mettre en oeuvre le ferai dit répondu
sur l'international alors la stratégie
elle et elle est peut être nuancé par
rapport aux pratiques précédent oui le
groupe sncf a vocation à être à
l'international
oui on est un grand groupe et la sncf
elle même coup ses filiales sont à
l'international par contre en matière
d'allocation de ressources mois et les
idées claires
ma priorité c'est le ferroviaire
français je considère que le prix dans
la république m'a mis en place pour que
le ferroviaire français fonctionne bien
en qualité et en maîtrise des coûts
voilà donc j'ai une priorité claire pour
moi l'international oui mais à la
condition que ça ne sont pas des
ressources de cash trop importante et
deuxièmement que ça rapporte de l'argent
et qu'on n'en parle pas voilà donc si
l'international ne coûte pas de cash
le cash est réservée principalement à la
france et si l'international rapport de
l'argent et cet argent pour venir nous
aider à financer les politiques curières
française alors oui il faut faire
d'international voile à côté de la
plaque il nuancé là la petite
conditionnalité que je rajoute dans le
recentrage stratégique que je souhaite
apporter à la sncf
vos exemples sont bons eurostar
souffrent beaucoup eurostar et comme les
tgv en souffrent beaucoup donc il ya un
sujet effectivement sur eurostar tu due
à la réduction drastique des échanges
entre la grande-bretagne et l'europe
continentale
keolis s'en sort pas trop mal parce que
keolis son business model c'est la dsp
avec les collectivités dans une forme
d'amortisseur alors il perd de l'argent
qu'ils honnissent mais c'est sépara trop
g donc et forme d'amortisseur grâce au
contrat geodis ce sujet puisque geodis
et grands logiciels mondiale et geodis
va bien car les échanges mystiquement
nous rend bien en ce moment ils vont pas
bien de geodis il ya des problèmes par
contre la chercheuse de geodis et que
geodis à une activité en asie assez
forte et tous les tous les experts tous
les experts et économistes prédisent que
l'asie notamment la chine va repartir
plus tôt et plus donc geodis souffrent
les geodis peut-être aura le bénéfice
d'une reprise de la production
industrielle en asie
les échanges qui pourraient qui pourrait
en découler sur leur programmation des
travaux
oui on reprogramme et chers collègues je
suis capable
qu'est ce que ça va faire mais bien du
retard à l'évidence il peut dire des
problèmes d'argent ondule au plan de
relance sur un plan de relance forte
surdité par structure ça ça aidera il ya
de tout manière d'un terreau mécanique
ni retards accumulés vont obliger à
reprogrammer les choses et certaines
dates d'ouverture qui était prévu où est
remise en question
ouais je ne vois pas comment alors que
tout était déjà très tendu moment nous
allons faire pour rattraper plusieurs
mois le décalage free sur les travaux
donc il y aura des problèmes de dates à
coup sûr et éventuellement des problèmes
or isation en sarthe ce kid ce qui nous
renvoie aux sujets financiers que que
j'ai évoqués sur les aspects sociaux
alors d'abord pour ceux qui connaissent
moi le sujet les sénateurs qui
connaissent moins la semaine ce n est
pas tout seul qui s'appelle qui est à
l'utp qui est gérée par me l'endettement
et ferroviaires le sous-quartier
roberval ferroviaires l'utp et donc tous
les acteurs du ferroviaire seront
regroupées dans une banque
la vocation d'une branche c'est de
construire une convention collective
nationale
donc c'est un processus qui est en cours
et la com comme l'a dit la sénatrice tôt
il ces processus a connu un coup d'arrêt
puisque la partie de cette convention
qui était relative à la corde sur la
classification et la rémunération a été
bloqué par deux syndicats
mais trois autres syndicats s'y sont
opposés bon et dans les règles que sont
les nôtres l'opposition des 300 cas n'a
pas rendu possible la signature d'un
accord sur cette partie n'a donc sonné
un peu arrêté une manière de sauter
l'obstacle effectivement une possibilité
lancer dans l'état de répondre c'est pas
moi c'est d'aller dans l état peut
prendre la main et par ordonnance
effectivement il peut traiter ce sujet
je je je ne je n'y serai pas défendre
parce que je pense que là des tarifs y
est ce n'est pas bon comme la
concurrence arrive par ailleurs je pense
qu'il est important de clarifier
l'ensemble du cadre social qui
s'appliquera aux entreprises
dans le cas de la concurrence et donc
devant le constat qu' on n'a pas réussi
à passer à passer que tu as passé le cas
de la signature de cet accord
je rappelle que deux syndicats étaient
quand même d'accord donc il n'est pas si
mauvais que ça cet accord il était un
accord de qualité me semble-t-il
voilà peut-être que les pouvoirs publics
et notamment le ministère des transports
prendra ses responsabilités en allant en
clarifiant les conditions sociales qui
était qu'on a essayé de traiter par
d'accord voilà ce que ce que je pouvais
alors sur sur la ligne d'al ahly la
ligne nouvelle paris-normandie que vous
évoquez je sais qu'il ya des besoins
normandie j'en suis parfaitement
conscient je me suis occupé il ya
quelques années c'est de ces lignes je
les connais bien
donc oui il ya des besoins
d'amélioration du réseau et je comptais
sur moi en tout cas pour soutenir ces
lignes je connais l'importance et puis
au fond de moi vous savez je suis
conscient aussi
cette émission l'eau verte d'ailleurs
qu'on a quelques parties du territoire
qui n'ont pas bénéficié l'effet tgv
il ya un sujet un peu de d'égalité des
territoires donc je vous dis pas qu'on
fera des tgv sur la normandie je vous
dis pas qu'on fera du tgv sur le
lauberhorn mais il me paraîtrait normal
d'avoir des programmes sur des trains
classiques sur les lignes classiques il
permet de réhabiliter leur revenir sur
ces territoires bien merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le président je
mangerai évidemment skalli nelly
tocqueville en tant qu'élu normand je
pense que jean michel gagnon ne me
dérangerait pas pour des faits pour
rappeler le président pépy disait
souvent que la sncf avait il dit en ce
qui concerne la lnpn on sait bien que ce
n'est pas une décision qui relève de la
sncf mais de l'état c'est bien aussi que
malheureusement cette infrastructure et
et remise assez loin dans le temps mais
il n'en demeure pas moins au contraire
justement il est nécessaire de faire en
sorte que les lignes qui existent en
normandie ce se voient leur situation
s'améliorer
voilà je me suis permis ce n'est pas
dans mes habitudes cette petite
parenthèse normande pour rebondir sur
votre propre au final de ce président je
voudrais ça va simplement remercier vous
voulez les présidents qui vous
accompagne et monsieur fanny chez
monsieur de l'ordre pour cette audition
qui a été très très intéressante et très
riche qui a permis d'aborder beaucoup de
sujets d'aujourd'hui de demain et
d'après demain de parler des questions
sanitaires des questions de sécurité des
questions de relance des questions
d'environnement
je regrettais c'était très important
vous avez fait un certain nombre de
propositions fortes notamment sur la
question obligatoire le port du masque
vous avez compris que nous souscription
et que nous aurions à coeur de relayer
vos propositions notamment celle là mais
pas seulement salda auprès auprès des
pouvoirs publics
vous le savez mais je le redis parce que
c'est souvent en période de crise que
c'est bon de pouvoir compter sur ses
amis vous avez l'eau sein du sénat et de
notre commission en particulier beaucoup
d'amis et nous ferons en sorte de
pouvoir vous aider à traverser cet appel
difficile et assurer non seulement la
pérennité mais le développement de notre
entreprise
voilà merci beaucoup seul président
et je n'en doute pas très bientôt et
merci à mes collègues qui ont participé
à cette audition
merci beaucoup à ces jo énorme merci à
vous tous merci beaucoup
sinon j'aimerais no mercy mercier
président remparts